This is Jocko podcast number one 14 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And tonight we have a guest on the podcast for the fourth time.
The fourth appearance,
which is no surprise really because this is a guy that I went to war with,
started a business with,
wrote a book with.
I actually watched him get married and have kids and buy houses and go from a,
let's say a wild single man going to live a Friday night.
Like it was his last night ever
to a guy with a diaper in one hand and a bag of Cheddar bunnies in the other
hands trying to tame his son,
who at one years old was like a hardheaded borderline psychotic version of
himself.
And I also saw this guy in much harsher environments and in some of the most
challenging situations I saw him bear the incredibly heavy weight of leading men
in combat
and also the crushing weight of losing some of those men.
I still see that weight on his shoulders.
Can I see it in his eyes?
And I wish I could take some of it away.
Yeah,
but I can't,
they end
as we learn.
Okay.
In the seal teams we don't complain.
Yeah.
We shoulder our share
of the weight,
which shoulder our share of the burden and we drive on.
Okay.
And I've
seen him stand up when I needed him to stand up
when what I was asking for was more than I could have asked or should have
expected from anyone.
And I watched him time and time and time again move out,
move out into the darkness,
toward the unknown,
toward the violence,
toward the enemy who's mission was
to Maine or to kill him
and his men.
But he went and he went every time and he went without fail
and his name is Leif Babin.
And if you want a more thorough background of leaf,
you can listen to the other times that he's been on this podcast.
He was on number 11 number 34 number 65 you should listen to those first before
you listen to this one.
You can also read the book that we wrote.
It's called extreme ownership.
It's about our experiences in combat and the leadership lessons we learned
there.
But for now,
here we are once again in life.
Welcome back to the show.
Thanks for having me on.
And we had a couple of different options on what we were going to do this time
around and tweeted out,
you know,
if anybody has any questions and we got a lot of questions so I know I can
answer questions.
We'll just say in a really in a very in depth manner from time to time and we
got a lot of questions.
So I,
I,
you know,
we,
we just took down a bunch of the questions and I'll read through some of them
and we'll try and burn through a bunch of these questions that we got from
everybody.
Let's get some ready.
Get some,
like I said,
life is always ready to get Sophie,
which is static stand buddy gets on standby to yes for,
for people that didn't know,
don't know what that means.
And we often put that out on social media.
I don't think people recognize what that actually means.
So it's like we,
we knew we'd say this all the time in combat or in training scenarios when you
knew that,
I mean it was about to go down bullets,
we're going to be flying around,
exposure going to be going off and you hear someone very clearly over the radio
just in a real combo is come up and be like stand by.
It gets them.
Yeah.
So get a chuckle out of that every time.
I always get a chuckle out of that one.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a true statement though,
right?
You know,
you're,
but when you could say it in that manner,
you know,
when you should be like,
Yo,
let's do that.
Or in the job and,
and people were like stand by to get some,
yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
I was on my first deployment and we were driving driving south from Baghdad and
we got ambushed and we were like out for like a five or six vehicle convoy and
the ambush hit the tail end.
I wasn't,
I was in the number two vehicle as normal for,
you know,
for platoon commander at the time.
I'm in the number two vehicle,
the tail end of the ambush gets ambushed or tail,
the convoy gets camp ambushed.
And
what I mean it's very clear,
it's RPGs are going over the convoy and explosions and machine gun fire.
And it's really obvious we're getting ambushed and what we're on a highway and
we're moving fast.
So we,
you know,
it's,
I was like a push through,
you know what I mean?
Like we didn't stop at all,
didn't even hesitate.
And then we continued down the road and I asked for the um,
you know,
like UPC count from the ribs up count.
And so it was,
you know,
I hear like Google six is up,
we will call five is up and the vehicle for us up and it gets the front and I'm
like,
Roger,
we're up,
keep it rolling.
And then another,
maybe another minute goes by.
And My platoon chief,
great guy,
he's in the back vehicle rear in the rear of vehicles cause that's how you
break,
you know,
break it up.
So if something happens,
he's in controller and,
and he comes up in the radio and he's like,
he's like,
Hey sir,
just you just want to let you tell me.
We got ambushed her back here.
Did you know that?
And I go like this,
Roger,
we got back.
We had a good laugh about that one but uh,
it was pretty good times.
So awesome.
Yeah.
All right,
get into some questions.
This is a question that actually came very similar questions that I had when it,
when it had Tony on.
And most of these questions,
cause I said these questions are for life coming on the podcast and most of them
are directed at you and I'll,
I'll,
I'll chime in or whatever if I feel the need.
But you like that.
So here we go.
First and one life.
How often did you disagree with Jocko was commands and how many times did you
actually let them know also how did your handle either situation?
So there you go.
I disagree with Jocko every minute.
We actually,
we had a,
it's a great question and look,
Jack and I are different people.
We have different views of the world.
We have,
uh,
there were,
there were times when his job was,
your job was strategic and you're looking at the bigger strategic picture.
My job was tactical.
I'm looking at the tactical picture.
Sometimes you can make a tactical decision that could impact the strategic
mission and ever.
It was very rare though that we ever had any kind of disagreement on those
things.
Uh,
I think,
um,
you know,
there were,
there are a number of times that when,
uh,
what,
what I always liked about Jocko and I think people look at you and think,
oh,
he's just big intimidating guide at our member.
Uh,
our commanding officer actually,
um,
we were talking to them and of course he loved our task unit and he was like,
yeah,
you guys Bruce.
He was like,
he was talking to me and,
and a Delta platoon commander and uh,
and said,
you guys,
you got to do a jock who says,
oh,
he's,
he'll choke you out.
And we were kind of laughing about that cause we were,
we were training Jujitsu every morning.
I'm like,
man,
I've been choked out by Jaco hundreds of times.
It's not even a threat anymore.
But uh,
it was,
it was never,
we never did what you said because it was fear or intimidation or like we have
to do what he says because he's in charge.
What I always loved about you and your leadership was that I knew that I could
push back on stuff and you're going to listen to me.
And it was uh,
it was engineering interesting for me to see that as,
you know,
we built a relationship.
I could,
I could come in and be like,
Hey,
I think we ought to do this.
And,
and,
and very rarely would you are,
you would never say like,
no,
do it this way cause it's my way.
But even very,
very rarely would you would you say sometimes you might bet,
well,
we want to go in this direction and here's why we want to do this.
But most of the time you would actually just say,
hey,
we'll talk me through that.
Okay,
how's that going to work?
And you would give me the opportunity and others in the,
between the opportunity to come up with a plan and kind of analyze it and look
at it and,
and give it,
give it a shot.
And so that's,
that's where I live.
I always loved about,
uh,
about that.
I mean a couple of disagreements that that came up,
uh,
you know,
for,
for me something that we talk about all the time,
you know,
with our business echelon front and when we talking in talking to companies and
leadership teams,
going to the workup cycle,
you know,
we always talk about people want to hire folks and just kind of let them,
let them run and,
and you know,
people won't say,
Hey,
give them,
give him the opportunity to go out and succeed.
And A,
and a lot of bosses want to kind of,
you know,
we'll just,
hey,
I'm really busy.
Hire someone with experience,
put them,
put them in and position you kept really,
really tight reins on us.
Uh,
and initially that was super frustrating to me.
I mean,
I,
I remember being in our mount training military operates urban terrain training
for folks that don't know what that means.
We're,
we're,
we're in the mock cinder block city and we've talked about that on the podcast
and talk about that often here for,
for other folks at other podcasts.
But,
uh,
that was it.
I wanted to plan these things.
I'm the platoon commander and I want to be in charge.
I remember you saying,
Hey,
we should do this or let's plan it this way or,
and I remember wanting to kind of push back against that and a,
and oftentimes,
uh,
but I recognize like as we're going along,
you're actually training me and given me the,
the,
uh,
given me up to you,
you've done a whole bunch of these operations that I hadn't done any of those
operations previously.
So,
uh,
you,
you were teaching me and mentoring me and,
and once we got to the battlefield,
you just unleash,
just have to get after it.
And a couple of times I do remember some push back where you came up and gave me
some direction and uh,
you know,
were,
uh,
you said,
hey,
why don't you try this or do that?
And one of those times in particular was when I was,
you know,
what I was trying to get,
get,
uh,
I remember a number of times and one of them out it in our desert,
training facility out at what be called land warfare.
And,
uh,
I'm trying to get the platoon,
um,
to,
uh,
to pull back to a position and we're trying to try on a patrol out.
And you gave me,
um,
he,
he told me to actually stop trying to put,
put a bunch of detailed information out of the radio,
like Jews verbal commands do it this way.
And I,
you know,
immediately my ego getting the way I was in,
it was frustrating because the team wasn't doing what I want them to do.
And that's like step number one in the frustration.
So I team isn't doing what I wanted was so automatically my meters kind of
starting to get pegged and like,
you know,
the rag,
no one's listening to me.
So when Jocko comes up to give me some direction of like,
hey,
you ought to do this,
my immediate pushback is like,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
You know,
I didn't say that,
but I,
I just,
I was like,
I kind of bristled a little bit.
I remember kind of Breslin at that and I was like,
okay,
let me think about it.
Um,
what do we,
you know,
uh,
he hasn't told me wrong before.
And I was like,
let me give that a shot.
I was like,
okay,
I'll do that.
Use verbal commands,
get,
get her by moving dude.
And you do that over and over and over again throughout multiple training
scenarios and then on the ballot as well.
We're,
we're,
that's what built up trust.
So when,
when you did tell me to do some,
I was like,
I'm going to give it a shot.
And,
and it worked.
It worked like magic.
Expand on that a little bit.
The verbal command thing is,
so you get guys that there's a bunch of people you know you've got,
you've got to protect the,
we'll just take this case,
you've got to tune of 16 guys there in various terrain features.
One guys in a little in a little low,
uh,
a ravine,
one guys up on a little knoll and other guys behind a stroke.
So there's a little bit of dispersion with your troops and you want to get them
to do something.
You want him to get him to fall back or you want to get them to muster where you
are and maybe the shooting stopped or whatever.
But you want to control all these people at the same time.
And so what you think is,
hey,
I'll just get on the radio and I'll tell everyone,
hey everyone,
I'm back about a hundred meters back.
There's a little piece of terrain sticking out.
There's a rock by it.
I'm behind that rock.
And if you guys start peeling back here to the northwest at about zero nine zero
degrees,
that's where you're flying me.
Okay.
So now what does that come across like on a transmission for a guy that's
shooting them a machine gun?
He hears like grown up,
got come back.
That's what he hears.
He doesn't hear anything.
And,
and so,
and you've given this long,
complex direction and what you really need is,
hey,
everyone fall back here.
Now that's what,
that's what they need to hear.
And so then you do it.
And he realized that now we have,
uh,
a thing in the seal teams where you pass the command.
And so when you hear a loud verbal command,
everyone passes it.
Now everyone heard it and now everyone comes back to your position.
But this is the essence of the book,
extreme ownership.
This is really the essence of simple.
Like it's simple,
clear communications.
And that's one of those things that once you learn it and you're like,
yeah,
if I,
if my people with my team isn't doing what I want him to do,
not that they don't want to,
they don't even know what do you want him to do?
Because you're giving it in such a complex way.
I S I gave that council hundreds of times.
Once I was running the training on the west coast.
I gave that council a hundred times like,
hey man,
just tell everyone a simple command right now to get them to do something.
So that holds true.
And I'll tell you,
I'll tell you another situation where you,
you kind of disagreed with me and we,
we,
we were working with a company,
I'm not going to mention the company's name.
We were working with a company and there was a,
a,
uh,
like a mid level but somewhat senior leader.
And you didn't like him.
And the reason you didn't like him because he wasn't really that confident.
He had messed some things up and his whole,
his division was suffering a little bit.
And you were,
you were kind of like,
hey,
Jocko,
we should talk about getting this guy fired.
Well,
it wasn't that he was,
it just wasn't that he was competent.
His division was suffering.
Like they were like,
Hey,
what's the dis guy
is dragging us down?
This is a major issue.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and I was,
we were getting massive negative feedback that was impacting the team,
particularly from a guy who was supposed to be,
uh,
the knowledgeable guy that was able to groom and mentor the Junior leaders
underneath him.
Uh,
and you know,
I thought,
man,
why should they keep this guy?
This is that he's actually dragging the team down.
Uh,
and you said,
well,
strategically it,
if they get rid of you,
I think get rid of this guy.
It's going to,
it's going to actually have some impacts.
The strategic mission,
they're trying to do it.
Yeah.
There's the senior leaders were going to quote,
you know,
maybe question what was going on there.
If you remove a key leader from so strategically at that point in the company,
that individual who was,
you know,
again we'll just say incompetent and also online,
he had really,
really good political and relationship connections with the,
we'll say a parent company,
but the people that controlled the funding and so we could get rid of this guy,
but all of a sudden all these people that were funding this company,
there was going to be problems.
And I was like,
Hey,
if we get rid of that guy,
we're going to cut a lot of relationship courts.
So we,
let's try and find a way to mitigate as much as we can do.
And we disagreed upon it.
But basically,
you know,
you've fundamentally got the other leader in that division to figure out how to
work with the guy and got him trained up and then that guy took enough control
that they mitigated the non-performer kind of out of the picture and it worked
out well.
Um,
I think the lesson there is that,
you know,
like I mentioned earlier,
like you can win the tactical battle and lose this,
the strategic a war and you certainly don't want to do that.
I think you've got to recognize when you're,
whether it's terminating someone or making decisions.
Uh,
I think that's where we had,
you know,
you had that strategic picture in mind and I was focused a little more on the,
on the tactical side.
So,
um,
you gotta you gotta keep,
you can make the right tactical call and can have some real strategic
consequences,
you know,
the cascade and cause you a lot more problems.
I think though that the,
my true answer,
this question on our most fundamental disagreement came on patches and uh,
that was,
uh,
Jocko was understood as seals that we needed to be squared away.
We wanted to be storm troopers and t you bruiser that's what we wanted to,
we wanted to all look the same.
We wanted to have,
uh,
you know,
squared away,
haircuts,
quarter a uniforms,
everybody in the same,
same year.
That's hard for seals cause seals often want to just kind of where uh,
you know,
mix and match of uniforms and kind of whatever gear that they want to look cool,
straight up long hair,
beard to all those things you recognize that we needed to when you do that and,
and guys can get out of control.
We have all these patches made that are,
you know,
that are like look at these cool guy.
I've got patches all over me and,
and uh,
and,
and that's seals.
There's some of the best,
you know,
the biggest offenders of that.
So Jocko was like no patches.
And just to expand
on this a little bit more,
but strategically from the army,
from the Marine Corp,
the army in the Marine Corps,
when they look at someone that's not in a square to you two squared away
uniform,
they think they think to themselves,
Hey,
if this guy can't even wear a squared away uniform,
how can he operate out in the battlefield?
And that that's what,
what they think and good for them because it's a true statement.
If you've got someone that can't mind some,
some details and look squared away,
then how can,
how can I expect them to do their job?
Well now in the,
in the seal teams and really in all soft communities,
there's some absolute laxity when it comes to uniform requirements.
That's why you see pictures of guys doing this,
uh,
you know,
dressing out of uniform and mix and match in uniforms.
It's,
it's the way it is.
And you know what my,
in my,
in my deepest knowledge,
I know that you can have,
and this is a classic military quotas,
you know,
uh,
an inspection ready platoon has never passed combat and a combat ready platoon
has never passed inspection.
It's,
it's a commonly known thing that I understand and I get and,
but especially where new in the battlespace,
we're just showing up here.
We got,
you know,
marines and Army soldiers and senior leadership that we're going to be working
for.
And I say,
okay,
we're gonna make this is the bait.
The fundamentally,
we're going to make a good first impression.
We're going to look square it away,
which means we're gonna,
you know,
have squared away haircuts.
We're going to bounce our boots and we're going to wear a normal looking
uniform,
which means we don't have crazy looking patches that,
that make us look different.
Right.
Cause it's,
that's the thing that you're saying,
the thing that you're saying is look at me.
That's what you're saying.
Look at me.
I'm cool.
That's what a patch is.
It's,
hey,
look at me.
I'm special.
And,
and,
and obviously I don't like that attitude.
And so here we go back to the patches.
So we,
I mean when you told me we were,
we were on board with everything on the same page and we saw eye to eye on so
many things.
It certainly me and the Deltona commander,
uh,
would you?
Absolutely.
And,
uh,
but that was,
I don't know why,
but for one reason we got together.
I was like,
we designed our own patches where like,
where when you say we,
you mean you and the Delta,
me and the Delta platoon commander,
we,
me and the Delta commander said we're going to design some batches for task and
bruiser and I don't know.
I don't know.
Why have we just had an idea that this was going to be a historic unit.
This is going to be something we want it to be a part of,
but we felt like we needed to tasking it backs.
And I felt like you secretly wanted us to have them even though you told us not
to do it.
So sounds like we designed these badges.
One of them I use the Lord humongous from the road warrior,
uh,
for one and a.
The other one we had a,
we had a big cow skull and a,
and it was,
so we had these two dispatches without,
we had a maid.
So we,
I secretly had them shift.
I secretly had them distributed to,
uh,
to both platoons.
And we keep them in our shoulder patch pocket and we'd be,
uh,
so we'd be in a convoy ready to roll out.
Jocko would come out,
see everybody off,
shake hands with everybody,
uh,
and we'd be launched on the operation and that we'd come up over the radio,
my leading pet,
how should come up with a ready and be like patches on everyone,
pull the badges out,
slap the badges on it.
And then we,
although we got busted when there was an embedded reporter with a,
there was an embedded reporter,
uh,
with one of the units we were working with and there were some photos of
patches.
So we got busted.
Although you didn't,
you didn't come down on me hard like that.
You just,
I just,
cause you mentioned that we had this conversation on text the other day and I'm,
I'm actually good.
I just pulled out my phone to read this text back and forth.
We were just talking about,
um,
you were basically saying,
hey,
you know,
you,
that's not forget you didn't want us to wear patches and,
and,
and then,
and then I wrote back to you a,
don't forget that while I was out outwardly disapproving inside,
I was smiling.
Knowing that a little rebelliousness isn't important is important for leaders to
possess and that a spree decor trumps compliance and uniformity.
Oh,
that's an actual text conversation we were having.
That's kind of jacked up isn't it?
But my point is like you got,
you know,
obviously it meant something to you and it was bringing the team together.
It's to swing.
When you go through boot camp and the drought,
Joan instructors will let you get away with something because they know it's
unifying the team.
And that's what it was for me.
I was like,
okay.
And also how much leadership capital am I going to expand?
Because even though I just made it sound like there's a big deal at that.
And also we had earned a good reputation.
We,
it wasn't a first impression anymore.
It was like the impression had been made.
And the impression was solid.
And so now it's like,
oh yeah,
these guys are these guys.
Oh yeah,
they,
they're actually a unit identifying patch.
So we actually,
and we gave that patch to the brigade commander department,
which was awesome.
And I'm very proud to say that,
uh,
there's not a whole lot up on the wall and the Jocko Gym,
but uh,
in the garage there.
But,
uh,
but there is a t you bruiser pads.
Lord humongous represents,
there's a seven echo from my,
from my echo platoon at team seven.
And there's a seal team one patch.
I mean,
a sticker.
That's my,
that's my,
uh,
wall of glory
stapled to the wall.
Awesome.
All right,
next question.
So that's the one question that we're 20 minutes deep.
You gotta like that.
Um,
all right.
Next question.
Can you discuss the evolution of Echelon Front?
Was the company ready for the explosive popularity of extreme ownership?
What kinds of challenges have you faced?
We faced all kinds of challenges and the same challenges that a,
that any business faces,
uh,
certainly.
And you know,
for,
for us,
it's been learned to the firehouse.
It's been,
it's been an awesome experience.
I mean,
I,
I think,
uh,
just like any,
just like our,
our combat experience,
we would adapt to the battlefield.
We learned,
we educated ourselves about things that we didn't know about and,
and,
uh,
and we've grown.
I mean,
I don't think anyone could,
I don't know if we could have predicted just how widely disseminated the the
book would be or,
or,
uh,
you know,
the popular of the things that we're talking about.
We knew they were powerful.
It's a whole reason we wrote the books.
There was a massive demand signal for it.
And,
uh,
and I think,
you know,
as we work with companies now through a,
I'll come national on fraud.
I mean,
there's just,
we're,
we're able to go and,
and deliver a,
some impact to teams,
uh,
in a way that other people aren't able to do it.
Because most of the folks in that space are,
it's a feelgood thing.
You're out there to talk about,
hey,
you guys,
you're great and let's harness your inner potential and all this kind of stuff.
And I laugh when people call us motivational speakers because a,
I say motivational speakers tell you how good,
good you are.
And we're here to tell you how much you suck and be better.
You got to get better if you want to win.
So,
um,
that's what we do.
And I think it's the same,
same way that,
that,
that brutally honest assessment of yourself,
your team,
the same thing that makes you know,
seal unit successful on the battlefield and other military units is the same
thing that we're doing now with our company.
Certainly,
you know,
all the challenges of,
of bookkeeping and,
and,
and uh,
you know,
the billing processes and,
and pay in taxes.
And I mean,
just the regulatory environment,
those things that,
that make it hard for any business launching a,
but just like on the battlefield where we can either bitch about the paperwork
or we could figure out a way to most efficiently get it done so that we could
actually go accomplish the mission,
uh,
which you instilled in us.
Like,
Hey,
I can complain about it all day.
I can figure out a way to get this done and make it happen because that's what
it requires to do.
And that's what we're doing with our business.
Uh,
and it's,
it's been awesome.
And,
and frankly,
you know what I love is working with leaders in so many of the folks that
contact us that want to work with us there,
they're already doing well and they want to do even better.
And,
and it's just so much fun to work with folks who want to just constantly grow
and learn and we grow and learn all the time from them.
Yeah.
I think you hit it all.
Mex Quest in battle,
having the high ground is crucial.
How do you see this principle applied to the business world?
And,
and we have,
I've answered this question before with the statement,
take the high ground to the high ground.
We'll take you.
So business world.
Okay.
Well tactically,
what do you think the high ground,
well though I think that's the,
that's the real question,
right?
Why is the high ground important?
And obviously,
you know,
out of thousands of years of military history,
um,
the,
the high grounds always important by the way.
I did have a,
I did have a training instructor a few years ago.
My,
my seal team days who we had,
he said,
look at your high speed altimeter watch and uh,
and,
and you get get down behind something.
So he was basically telling us like,
if that thing's going up,
you're wrong.
That she thinks she'd be going down.
He was,
he was telling us to take the low ground,
which was,
uh,
which was kind of laughable.
So outdoing thousands of years of,
of military history always take the low ground.
No,
don't do that.
You want to take the high ground.
The reason is because tactically,
if you're on the high ground,
you,
you have got a better shooting position.
You can shoot down on people who can't hide very well because you,
you,
you're above them.
Which is why it was awesome for us to be in buildings.
And if we could get a three or four story building in this,
you know,
in the city,
reminding the urban environment,
we,
it was awesome.
It's no different in the business environment.
And,
and what you have to do is just identified the key terrain.
What is the key to the high ground is key terrain.
Uh,
so it doesn't,
it doesn't
necessarily mean that you know,
you're going to go climb to the mountain top because that's where you want to
be.
Uh,
but,
but if,
if that ridge line that's on the high ground gives you tackle vantage on the
battlefield,
that's,
it's the same thing in the business world.
If you're,
if you're a retailer,
you know,
where's that key terrain?
Where's the intersection that,
that's,
that you want to be,
that's going to give your business the best,
uh,
you know,
the best chance to succeed if you're,
um,
you know,
any space.
I mean,
there's,
there's key terrain that you can identify where you want to be a part of.
If it's,
if you're a private equity company and you're trying to break into some new,
some new technology or new,
uh,
a new new,
particular industry,
that's,
that's key terrain.
You need to be focused on that and identifying that as critical,
why it's important.
Um,
and,
and everyone's going to be going to be vying for that.
And you want to be aggressive if you want to a maneuver a,
because if you get there first,
um,
you're going to be a lot better position.
It's,
it's flanker be flank.
We always say,
you know,
your maneuver on the enemy and they're gonna maneuver on you.
Um,
so what you don't want to do is wait for somebody else to get in a better
position,
and then you actually have to fight your way out of that.
It's,
it's not good.
Like,
and Jujitsu,
you don't want to wait to,
someone's going to mount you.
That's not a good place to be or take your back.
Right?
You want to try to prevent that before we can get there.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and if you can do that to them first and you're in a much better position.
And I think it's no different.
And the business world,
I had her,
it was working with a company the other day and basically what they were saying
was that their competitor was lying about them too,
too.
As they're trying to close accounts there,
their competitor would go in the field and say,
Oh yeah,
this,
the company are this to this company.
They don't do it right.
And they don't have these accounts and they're,
they're going out of business and everything's bad.
So there's,
there's their competitors were out there lying about them and you know,
the sales leader said,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want to stoop to their level,
you know,
and,
and start throwing lies out there about them or making accusations.
I think that's,
you know,
I said,
well,
no,
you don't want to take the low ground.
You want to take the high ground.
And he said,
well,
yeah,
but at the same time,
what,
what are we supposed to do?
And I said,
well,
you actually have the most powerful weapon in this fight.
The weapon that you have is the truth.
You have the,
you have the truth,
but you're not getting the truth out there.
I said,
what do you do when you do close an account?
What do you do?
How do you publicize it needs to cool?
We really don't.
And I said,
well,
do you,
do you do a press release when you closed a big account?
No,
we don't do that.
Do you advertise it anyway?
No,
we don't do that.
I said,
so the most powerful weapon you have is the truth and you're not utilizing that
weapon.
Do you need to have a propaganda arm at this company that's going to go out
there and explain that though all the wins and what the truth really is and that
will be more powerful.
And then you can maintain the high ground.
And by the way,
when those other companies are out there lying about you and then people find
out,
it makes them look even worse.
So they've broken their trust with,
with the potential client.
So,
yeah,
always take the high ground.
Always take that ground.
It might not win you the short term battle in business,
right?
Um,
you know,
you see,
you see companies,
you know,
like,
uh,
I can sell you this thing right now.
I can,
I can paint this thing,
put a fresh coat of paint on it and sell it to you.
That's not the high ground,
right?
That's the low ground.
Cause it's gonna.
It's gonna fail you cause it's on what's underneath the hood is crap.
So that might win me,
you know,
that one sale.
But what's going to happen in the long road?
Taking the low ground,
you're gonna,
you're gonna put on Yelp that you got a crappy deal.
And I did.
You know,
I repainted something and sold it to you and it wasn't worth it.
And now that reputation is going to spread and it's not going to help you if you
take the high ground,
hey,
here's what's going on with his vehicle or whatever you're selling,
take the high ground.
There's all closing.
That is,
is we,
we see so many leaders and some of those successful people.
We do that recognize how important that is to build relationships and they're,
they're willing to,
to lose a sale or lose,
uh,
you know,
to send someone to a competitor just to,
just to make sure that person gets exactly what they need and they're building
relationships.
So that means more business gets sent to them.
It's what you started off talking about.
It's a strategic win as opposed to a tactical wind and that,
and that's what you've gotta be focused on.
And that's really as a leader,
that's what you gotta be looking at it.
You gotta be looking at your front line people and making sure that they,
they're not just out there trying to win every little tactical battle,
but they're going backwards strategically.
So keep that in mind.
That's why you have to detach.
That's why you have to stay out of the weeds.
And when you get in the weeds,
you got to step back out of them because otherwise you lose track of that and
you're going to end up in a low ground before you even recognize it.
All right,
next question.
How do you control rumors and gossip within an organization?
That's pretty easy.
You just,
you just talked about being,
you know,
getting out there for the truth and your propaganda arm to outside your company.
It's no different inside your company.
You've got to make sure that people,
I,
it's interesting that when you were,
we work with leaders sometimes you see people that are like,
well,
I don't want to share those with my people.
You know,
cause I don't know what they might think.
Like they're,
or they're thinking something that may be totally not true.
They're not just sitting there not thinking anything because you're not sharing
it with them.
They're coming up to their own conclusions,
which may be completely false or opposite.
But like we say in the,
in the,
in the navy all the time,
you know,
perception is reality.
That becomes reality.
So you've got to,
you got to,
you can defeat the gossip and rumors by actually just sharing the truth.
Be Open with people and uh,
and,
and be in first out there with a message so people get an understanding.
And even when horrible,
bad things go wrong,
extreme ownership,
right?
If,
if you take ownership for that and say,
Hey,
listen,
this happened.
Here's what we're doing to fix it.
Here's what we're doing to turn things around it.
It's going to be people.
People are not going to lose respect for you and the organization.
They're actually going to gain respect for you as a result.
Something we talk about all the time.
So don't be afraid to do that again,
just get the message out there and,
and be transparent and talk to folks.
If you don't tell people what's going on,
they're going to make up their own ideas of what's going on and the thing that I
have to,
yeah,
I have to,
we have to,
we have to take this just a little bit further,
right?
Just a little bit further because we talk about transparency,
And that word gets thrown around all the time and have the idea that you're just
going to use that,
the idea that you're just going to tell everyone exactly what's going on and
that sounds great.
And it's like,
Hey,
I'm a fully transparent leader.
And I'm gonna tell her what's going on.
But there's times where you actually don't want to do that.
There's times where you have to maneuver and you have to be tactful and some of
the things that you might tell someone actually is not the right thing to do.
Now,
am I,
I'm not saying we're,
we're,
we're going to be dishonest with our people.
I'm not saying that and I'm saying that transparency's great thing,
but I mean,
just on a personal level,
if laughs,
laughs,
uh,
working for me and he's not doing what he's doing,
something horrible is the best way to go about that to fully true,
full transparency is,
Hailey,
you're doing horrible at this.
Is that the best way to do it in front of the entire team in front of the right
is that,
is that it's full transparency,
right?
Hey,
I'm fully transparent.
Okay,
everyone welcome to the meeting today,
by the way.
I just wanted to point it out that life mrs numbers again and he's a loser.
That might be what I'm thinking.
That's fully transparent.
Hey guys,
just be,
I need,
love this too,
right?
Just being transparent,
layoffs,
a loser.
He missed his numbers again.
And you know what?
I'm actually thinking about firing him just in case anyone was wondering.
So that's,
that's for trucks.
It's not going away to close of business Friday did I do a good job?
Right?
So,
so let's not get carried away,
right?
You know,
what is the smart way,
the smart ways to maneuver.
The smart way is to say,
okay,
lace not doing what he,
what he wants,
what he should be doing.
If I go and accuse him of failing,
what's his reaction going to be?
How's it?
So what do I do instead?
Instead I go,
I want to take ownership of it.
And so instead I say,
hey leaf,
you know,
hey comes in,
come to come conquer my office.
I want to talk to you about a couple of things.
So he comes to my office or not in a public place and now it's,
hey leaf.
Hey Man,
I noticed that you,
you know,
you,
you missed your numbers and I'm thinking that maybe I'm not giving you the kind
of support that you need to,
to get where you need to be.
Is there anything that else that you need from me so that you can win again
inside?
Sure.
I'm thinking Lafe you pathetic loser.
You missed your numbers again.
Right.
But I'm not going to do that.
So the full transparency thing,
I get it and it makes sense,
but we do have to consider the tertiary and the secondary and tertiary effects
of the things that we say,
especially as a leader.
What you say is a lot of impact as a leader.
And sometimes I see leaders,
they make a little off the cuff remark about something,
you know?
Oh,
that won't matter.
oh,
okay.
So it doesn't matter.
So,
so this little thing,
you know,
hey,
hey boss,
we wanted to get this task done by this date.
Is it still important?
Od doesn't matter.
Oh,
okay.
So it doesn't matter.
So when I was working on for the last month and a half,
doesn't matter.
Okay,
cool.
Great.
I was fully transparent.
So just be careful.
Use Tact.
Use your brain.
Yeah,
that's,
that's 100% correct.
I think,
you know,
what I was trying to explain in the,
in the first situation is I was having a conversation with a leader,
uh,
that we work with who was telling me that a,
there was a key leader in his team that didn't want to share with any of these
key leaders that they,
uh,
you know,
they,
they're the,
he didn't want to share with the key leaders that they were,
they were having as having some issues,
having some dire straights wonder,
you know,
getting to a point where they're wondering,
Hey,
I don't know if we're going to make payroll,
you know,
a few months from now if we don't turn these things around.
But I don't want to share that with them because I don't want him to panic.
And when I laugh when I heard that,
I was like,
uh,
what kind of panic or are they going to have when they find out they can't make
payroll but no one told them about and they thought everything was great.
So the pen is going to be a hundred times worse.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
that's the kind of transparency I'm talking about.
We were like,
listen,
you need to go and have a direct conversation and say,
guys,
here's where we're at.
Yup.
And that should be something to help get them in gear.
I'd be like,
listen,
we have got to,
we got to hit these numbers.
We've got to get things going again.
We've got a turn performance around our,
this is where we're going to be next quarter.
Uh,
if,
if we don't do that,
and I think those,
uh,
that's the kind of thing I'm talking about where you're not keeping the secrets
is not helping you out.
Because by the way,
everyone knows the numbers,
right?
So they know they're already probably know you're in dire straits and they're
thinking,
well,
I better find a backup job and they're going to leave and now you're an even
worse straight.
So yeah,
absolutely.
You don't need to hide information from,
from the team.
All right.
You know what,
we actually have like a few questions on the muster that people asked.
Uh,
one of them was,
why should I come to the master?
What do you think?
Why should you come to the muster?
Okay.
By the way,
the monster,
in case you don't know the monster's a leadership
event cause it seminar gathering,
gathering.
Oh,
okay.
I like it.
Get with that leaders.
So the masters or a leadership gathering where we get together and we talk about
leadership and we have them twice a,
well this one we're having twice a year.
Uh,
but anyways,
why should someone come to the monster?
What do you think?
Okay.
What I love about the muster is,
okay,
well you have to understand that we talked to hundreds of [inaudible].
We've,
we've actually worked with,
we talked to thousands of leaders over the last six years that we've had this
company echelon front,
worked with hundreds of companies in at about every industry you could imagine.
And we speak a lot of leadership conferences.
We speak at him all the time.
Uh,
and there is nothing like the muster room.
There just isn't anything out there like the Mussar,
nothing even comes close.
And the reason I love it,
I'm going to,
I,
I'm I guess get super excited to be there and be a part of that stuff.
And I even use words like magical to describe it on previous podcasts,
which I took some heavies for us,
it took a lot of heavies for out there.
It was pretty magical.
I guess there were a,
there was a pretty good like Disney,
Disney means Disney memes go in there.
That was pretty good.
But the,
the reason the is so amazing is
it's just different from anything else that we do.
And I think when I think about what really makes the muster different,
it's the people that are there.
It's the content that we're talking about.
And it's the impact that it has.
And you know,
so who comes to the muster?
The reason that's so awesome is that there are leaders from all over the place
and these leaders are hell bent on dominating their universe.
I mean,
these are people that are there.
They're in the game,
uh,
and they're from every type of business,
every type of industry.
I mean,
we have entrepreneurs,
we have senior executives from major companies,
we have mid level managers,
we have frontline leaders,
and we have people who really aren't even in a leadership position,
maybe with no direct reports,
but are aspiring to be that way and grow and learn.
Uh,
we get,
we get police and firefighters and other law enforcement officers,
members of the military,
and they're serving out there on our front lines of the home front and abroad
and a,
these are the most committed people I've ever met.
You know,
it's,
it's one way to quantify this or when,
when we're up in muster,
the,
like,
the hotel staff will,
will come up and there'll be like,
oh my God,
this is crazy.
Because for instance,
the doors to open to actually get in the morning of the monster,
they open at eight o'clock right?
Or I guess seven seven 15 or seven 45 because it starts at eight seven 45 the
doors open up and most,
I mean like you said,
we go to these conferences all the time.
Everyone was listening to it to some kind of conference and it's,
you know,
people are meandering around and there are so many that blade,
they don't really care at the muster.
It's like the doors open at seven 45 everyone's out in the hallway and we're not
in the hallway hanging out with everyone at you know,
seven o'clock and that's after we do a four 45 PT in the morning.
We do,
cause we do a little get some and that's another thing like the hotel people w
we'll clearing it with hotel,
which is letting them know like,
hey,
there's going to be a large gathering of people in,
in front of the hotel in the morning.
And they're like,
well what time?
But we were like,
oh,
four 45.
And they say,
well look,
Hey,
look how many people,
and we're like,
well,
there's 450 people here,
so there's going to be about 450 people here.
And sure enough,
there it is.
And that's what the whole musters like,
oh,
we say,
hey,
we're going to restart in 10 minutes.
And everyone goes out and they'd come back in in 10 minutes.
Everyone seated,
ready to rock and roll.
So that's,
that's the,
and that's,
it's funny to hear that from an outside perspective because we're in it,
but the hotel people always make comments about,
they say,
Hey,
we've never,
you know,
guy will say,
Hey,
I've been,
I've been running conferences here for 22 years.
I've never seen a group of people like that.
So that,
that to me shows you what kind of people show up at the muster when the,
and when the doors open and just bum rush in there to,
everyone wants to be in that front row.
They're engaged and they can ask and not just so they can,
uh,
you know,
so they can actually ask questions so they can actually engage with us.
And,
and that's what I love about those folks.
I mean,
they just,
they're not there to feel good about themselves,
right?
They're there to take a hard look in the mirror and a,
and learn and grow and get better and,
and,
and so they can better and B be more
effective leaders so they can lead and win in their teams,
whatever they happen.
You don't know.
So you just kind of talked about the,
the other question was a school comes to the monster and it's really every
different type of leader.
The,
another question that we got about the monster is what do we talk about at the
muster
for
what,
that's the other piece that I really like about it is,
is content,
right?
It's content that,
uh,
that,
that we talk about.
And of course,
I love telling war stories.
As you all know from the this podcast,
we like talking about war stories,
who'd like talking about our time and the teams.
And,
uh,
even when you just,
you put that photo up there of,
uh,
you know,
of Austin Ramadi from back in the day.
And I just,
it just brings back great memories.
I mean,
those will always be,
um,
some of the absolute best times of my life.
Certainly some of the worst times in my life as well.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but mostly some of the absolute best times in my life.
And,
and so we get to talk about that,
but not just in a way that's,
that's a,
that's a cool story.
But it has impact.
And I think taking the,
taking the combat leadership lessons and we talk about from extreme ownership
and applying them directly to a,
you know,
to,
to people's lives and what they do and how to overcome their challenges.
That's what it's about.
It's,
it's super engaging.
Uh,
and for us,
you know,
for,
for me and jog,
this isn't a standard leadership conference where there's like 40 different
speakers and the,
the main folks kind of get up there and spend a few hours.
I mean we're,
we're there the whole time and we're there to engage with leaders.
It's me,
it's Jocko,
it's Dave Burke,
it's JP Denelle from our echelon front team were there were the guys on stage
and even during the breaks,
we're talking to leaders that are coming up and asking questions.
We're,
we're engaging with them.
No green and Q and.
A,
there isn't a green room.
There isn't someplace where hiding behind the curtain,
there isn't.
Somewhere in the back were Lafe is getting a cucumber is put on his eyes,
take a load off sir,
sipping a sipping my Jocko white tea pinky look I,
and that's,
you know,
these,
these folks are there to get their questions answered and to ask hard questions.
The thing that you really,
we really get granular on a lot and that's,
that's what it is.
You're taking like,
you understand the principles.
It's like,
it's like learning a,
a Jujitsu move from one person and they teach you a fundamental basic move and
you're like,
okay,
I understand that.
And then compared to,
okay,
now you're getting,
getting a private lesson.
Like that's like an a class,
right?
Hey,
this is the arm lock.
Then you get a private lesson with someone that goes in and adapts the technique
to your body style,
to the opponents that you're facing,
the adjustments that you need to make.
That's the kind of granularity we get.
Cause the,
the,
the more you see these different angles.
And the other great thing is because with all these different people that you
got there,
and we do group exercises where now you're sitting down and we purposely don't
want people to sit with,
with industries that they already work with.
So in one group you'll get a,
a CEO,
you'll get a firefighter,
you'll get a startup business owner,
you'll get a mid level manager and you'll get it some,
you know,
regular corporate EVP and they'll all be sitting at the same table.
And we will give them a problem.
We'll give him a task and they'll come up with a solution and they'll relate it
to how it affects their lives and their business.
And when you see stuff from different angles like that and you're all applying,
we're all speaking the same language because everyone,
there's obviously read the book,
everyone understands that.
Everyone understands fundamentally what the principles are.
But now we're getting to see how they impact people's businesses and lives and
leadership roles from all these different perspectives.
And it just makes you that much better.
That's why during these exercises,
like I'll,
I'll say,
oh come to float around to these different tables and listen,
but the first day,
but I'll get to,
I'll be like,
oh man,
these guys are your,
I'm sitting there learning cause you got,
like I said,
you've got a firefighter that's explaining to a CEO what you do in a situation
where your team has decided that they're not gonna follow this procedure anymore
and they have good reason why they don't want to.
Like it's one thing when your,
when your team doesn't follow the procedure and you say,
Hey,
you got to follow this procedure and you,
and they say,
well why?
And you say you explain it to them and they go,
oh okay,
that makes sense.
But what about when you tell them to follow the procedure and they have a reason
that actually makes sense,
then what are you going to do?
Well,
that's what you learned at that,
at the muster.
That's where you make the progress.
So that's good.
One last question that we got about the,
the muster is what kind of impact do you see from people that have been to the
muster?
The impact is uh,
is is obvious in that the number of people who are there that are talking about
how they just got promoted or are they just got put in this,
in this position,
uh,
have greater responsibility and a and authority,
on their teams are,
they've been recognized for their exceptional performance?
Are The folks who've cove who've come back from that and we hear about it on
social media or reach out to us via email or come back to a muster to talk about
that from what they,
you know,
what had happened to them previously?
The number of leaders who come and see what we're doing and bring their teams.
That's what's pretty awesome too.
I mean that to me when a,
when a,
when a CEO from a company comes,
checks out what we're doing,
uh,
and brings 25 of his to his team members back,
to be a part of that because he recognizes the impact that,
that can have a to his,
to his team and we'll have,
and it's just,
it's awesome to see that.
I mean,
these are the most,
again,
the most committed people you could ever be around.
And they just,
they leave there with the knowledge to directly apply things to solve problems,
uh,
and they learn from us.
They learned from each other just as you said.
Uh,
and part of that too,
I think there's a recognition that these kinds of problems that I'm having are
not unique to me.
They're not unique to the market that I'm in.
They're not unique to my industry,
but their leadership problems and they,
and they apply everywhere.
Uh,
and I'm trying to get a diverse group of people to focus their efforts to,
uh,
and mutual support one another or accomplish a mission just like everybody else
in every other industry.
In the,
in the business world as a first responder,
the military doesn't matter.
It's the same thing.
Uh,
and the same techniques apply everywhere.
And it just,
uh,
that's why it's awesome.
I love the muster and,
and I,
I can't wait.
I can't wait to meet those folks.
Uh,
and uh,
and that's why so many people come back again and again and again.
And it's just a,
it's just an awesome event.
It's the best thing that there were a part of.
And a,
and frankly,
if you don't want to have that good look in the mirror,
that hard,
look in the mirror at yourself and have answer some tough questions about where
you can do better,
you probably shouldn't come because it's not for you.
It's a,
it's for people who are,
are eager to destroy their competition and dominate the universe.
And that starts with looking at themselves and taking ownership in solving
problems so they can win.
Yeah,
it's,
it's interesting cause if you think about it,
I was talking about this yesterday,
like every problem that you have in an organization is going to be solved by
leadership.
That that's it.
That's it.
That's what it's gonna get solved by.
Every problem that is in an organization is going to be solved by leadership.
I don't care if it's cause you're missing numbers.
I don't care if you've got bad process.
I don't care if you've got brown people in the wrong positions.
All of those problems are all about leadership because if you've got a bad
process,
there's a leader that's allowing that process to be in place.
If you've got bad people,
then there's a leader that's not either training.
Those people are getting rid of those people.
And if your P and l is upside down,
there's a leader that is not paying attention to the numbers.
So all of these problems are going to be used to prompt.
So if you want to improve your business,
well then what you needed to do is improve your leadership.
Now I will say this as well.
I just gotta make like a little caveat here cause you just talked about the
value of it.
If you're out there in the world and you can't afford to come to the monster,
which I understand the monsters is expensive.
It costs us a lot to put together.
I had somebody hit me up like,
hey,
it sounds like you care but more about making money.
I was like,
no,
we definitely want to make money.
That's what,
that's what we our business and we need to make money and we need to pay our
team and so yeah,
we are.
We are going to make money and the monster is expensive.
It costs a lot of money.
If you can't afford to come to the monster,
don't come to the muster.
If you can't,
don't go out and borrow money to come to the muster.
No,
you,
you're not,
you know,
don't skip a mortgage payment so you can come to the muster.
That's not a good idea.
What you do is you implement some financial discipline.
You start saving money,
you put it together and you can come to the next muster.
By the way,
if you can't afford the muster,
you can get a book called extreme ownership.
It costs 1697 on Amazon.
That's fine.
We,
this podcast is free.
There's 400 something hours of us talking about this kind of thing.
So you can do that.
Like I said,
if you can come to the monster,
that's when you're going to get basically a private jujitsu lesson.
You're going to learn really granular things.
You're going to get the interaction face to face.
You're going to have to ask the specific questions about your world and you're
going to interact with people that are on the same path as you.
That's awesome.
If you can come,
come,
we'll,
we'll see you at the muster that no green room thing and we've talked about that
before.
But that's,
that's a big deal.
It's a bigger than it might seem
because you know how like how you said like,
okay,
you have a Q and a part or um,
you know,
like you have a,
you have a specific question.
Like,
hey,
that was cool what you just said,
but what about the,
you know,
like some people have questions.
So during the break when most times I get these conventions and whatever,
they got the,
you know,
the people,
they'll,
they'll say their,
what they have to send them,
they'll go and they'll disappear straight up district newcomers on their eyes,
whatever,
grapes,
whatever.
And um,
but here it's like people are like,
Hey,
that question that I had,
now I can go run and go,
go grab,
lay for duck or whatever and ask it like personally,
it's what we have when during the break Lafe and I were on stage.
Yeah.
With a break we say,
okay,
take a break,
come back in 12 minutes we stepped down off the stage and we stand right there
and people just come and ask us more questions and we continued talking and
sometimes somebody has such a good question and we're like,
bring it back and we'll get back on stage and say,
hey,
someone just asked this question.
Here's the question.
It's a great question.
You know,
it's a problem time.
Yeah.
The whole time.
Even looking in the,
and this would happen to me a lot for some reason they think I know,
well I guess I kind of know a little bit,
but I'm going to ask you to the leadership questions always in the game,
like in the hallway and he said the best thing to do in that situation and you
want to just kind of,
cause
I was going to say that's one of the other primaries to come to musters Echo
Charles is going to be there one of these days.
We're going to get you on stage for a keynote presentation and it's going to be
awesome.
Yeah.
You gotta to be right,
right in your comfort zone.
Getting flanked.
All right,
moving on.
That was the three questions about the muster,
but they got asked.
So here,
knowing what you know about war and the teams,
if you could go back in time,
what would you have done differently?
Man,
I wish I could go back in time day.
Burke and I were doing an event
earlier this week and he was,
he,
he said,
uh,
you know,
I'm glad I'm not in Ramadi.
I know lave probably wished he was everybody 100%.
I would go there right now,
let's go and look.
It's what I would do differently is the recognition that,
uh,
we were super aggressive.
We took a lot of risk.
Um,
what I would do differently is I would actually be even more aggressive.
I would be a hundred times more aggressive.
I would be putting up,
you know,
a concept of operations brief for your,
for your approval to send up the chain to swim across the river and hit targets
and,
you know,
put in some cyber Overwatch's and just completely ruined the bad guys program
going on in south central.
My,
when they had complete freedom movement before they had any expectation that we
could be there before he met could get to us.
And I think,
uh,
they would never see it coming,
which means that,
uh,
we would have more impact and it would actually be safer for us,
because they wouldn't expect back in it.
So they would probably hammers.
But we recognize that we could get away with a lot more.
Um,
you know,
then we could,
uh,
and looking back on it,
I just,
when you,
when you come into an area and they're like,
hey,
don't go and you're all going to get killed,
he,
you want to be cautious.
You want to,
you don't want to just jump into things.
You want to mitigate risk and control.
Certainly.
Uh,
but we recognize we could get away with a lot more than we thought we could and
more often than not bring,
bring guys at home.
And of course,
that's the one that I would change.
Obviously if I could change,
if,
uh,
I would trade places with Mark Lee and Ryan,
Joe in my platoon in a second,
uh,
I'd trade places with Mike Monsoor and Delta platoon in a second.
And I wish I could do that and I can't,
but,
uh,
that is,
that is what I would change.
Um,
but,
uh,
I certainly would,
if we could go back there again,
we would be even more aggressive and we'd have even more impact.
There's a term that they used to say in the teams.
I don't know if you ever heard,
you probably did when we'd be doing special reconnaissance training and guys
would say trust your camouflage.
Did you ever hear that expression?
You may not have.
I don't.
I don't believe so.
So what it was was when you got good at putting your camouflage together,
you could really get aggressive in getting up and observing a target.
Because if you trust your camera,
if you've done a good job with your Cammie paint,
your Ghillie suit and d and,
and putting yourself together,
well the enemy's not going to be able to see you.
But it's really weird to be,
you know,
40 meters from a target that you're looking at.
Then there's a guy walking around and you feel completely naked.
Like they can see what they can't see you at all.
They can't see you at all.
And so it takes some,
it takes some time to learn to trust your camouflage.
And I think,
you know,
obviously hindsight is 2020.
And when you look back at your Mati like you look back and you think to
yourself,
what,
we could've done this and we could have done that.
We could have gotten closer to that target,
we could have done more things because our hindsight is 2020.
And also we learned over time to trust our camouflage.
And the longer we were there,
the the,
the more aggressive,
you know,
operations took place.
But yeah,
that's,
hindsight's 2020 isn't it?
That it is.
Okay.
Advice on restarting your life after the military.
I think you just got to figure out what you want to do.
Yeah.
You got to figure out what you want to.
I have a new mantra that I tell people now it's,
it's,
uh,
find your next mission and that's what you gotta do.
And I got,
I got really lucky because got right into this and you use the same thing.
Like we,
we went right into a new mission.
And so any time to kind of wander around and look around and figure out which
direction to go.
And by the way,
when you're wandering around and looking around to find out which direction to
go,
you're going to get pulled in a direction and that direction is probably going
to be the path of least resistance.
It's not going to be a good path.
We certainly know it's not going to be the path.
So when you come out,
when you get out of the military man,
have a mission to figure out what your next mission is going to be.
But I,
I would disagree with you there and that it wasn't that we'd got lucky right in
that and that if you think about what we're doing now,
this is what we like to do.
And this is what we,
we,
uh,
we brought lessons back from Marty that we,
we translating and gave to the next generation seals and,
and saw
the impact that was out.
I mean,
when you,
when you came back from my,
you could have any,
any job that you want to do and you said,
I want to go run trying to attachment because I want to make sure that the,
the next,
uh,
seals that are coming through this training and going forward to places like
Iraq or Afghanistan or ready,
uh,
you chose to do that.
And I was running a training program that that's,
I would,
I didn't want to be anywhere else in that.
It was awesome.
And I recognize how powerful that was.
Uh,
and,
and the kind of reward it brought to me to see these young officers go out there
that I put the training and,
and succeed on,
on incredibly difficult,
dangerous battlefields in different areas that,
that I'd been to.
So,
you know,
we,
we took that and recognize that this is something that,
that,
uh,
is useful,
it has impact and that we can do for others.
So I think that's,
it was absolutely not the path of least resistance.
And I got,
you know,
we had job offers,
offers that people thought people thought I was completely crazy,
a buddy of mine.
I was like,
come work for me,
we'll pay you this huge salary that was triple and what my navy salary was.
And I said,
I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to start my own business.
I mean,
he looked at me like I was nuts.
Yeah.
We were talking about yesterday because we weren't making a lot of money at the
beginning of echelon front.
Now where were we?
We were,
we,
we had to put together,
we were writing checks and paying for things and traveling on her own dime to,
to go and talk to companies and for free,
for free or for almost nothing.
And I think that's the,
and that's really it is,
is finding your mission.
Like this is what I can do a,
and this is,
this is what I liked to do and,
and I'm going to figure out a way to do something that is useful.
It impacts people.
Uh,
and I think that's,
that's a real key is fine to the next mission.
For sure.
Next question.
I like this question.
This question made me think that whoever wrote this question has a good feel for
like kind of the whole thing here.
So the question was,
he said this question to leaf,
what's Jockos most impactful strategy on you when he says life gets real fired
up?
Definitely someone who's been listening to a lot of podcasts or maybe he's
coming to the muster.
I heard,
heard us speak or top before cause Jocko talks about angry lavey late and it
really,
I can get angry.
That's psychotic,
right?
Basically be a little bit of a hothead.
I can definitely be a hothead.
He can be a lot of bit of audit.
Sometimes I can't and usually,
I mean I,
I uh,
I'd like to think that it takes me,
uh,
I,
I don't immediately spit up on things,
but once I get spun off I get,
I get really spun off.
And uh,
I don't know if you disagree with,
no,
no.
I was going to ask you is how has having two kids for sure that,
that that teaches you some temper control?
Big Time,
big time.
And it,
and particularly when,
you know,
when,
when there's,
there's timelines that you're trying to meet and we're trying to run a business.
They don't,
cause they don't,
they just do.
The timeline is now,
I want some crayons now.
And what I've,
what I've loved is that I love spending time with my son and uh,
and,
and my daughter,
and they're awesome kids in particular.
My son now he's three,
he's old enough to kind of,
you know,
he,
he's
in the game.
Yeah,
we'll go,
we'll go somewhere,
do something fun or are we're hanging out.
And it doesn't matter if that's five minutes long or five hours long,
like when it's time to leave,
it's level 19 meltdown every time.
Right.
And He,
I,
I'm waiting for the time.
He was like,
Dad,
thank you for the time.
This is really fun.
It doesn't happen.
So,
so yeah,
that,
that actually instills in you some,
uh,
some patients,
but it's the,
we always talk about red flags and that's something that I learned from you.
Um,
and that,
uh,
and I know you were looking at for me to see like,
oh some red flags are going off,
red flags are those things that as you talked about often you recognize in
yourself like okay I'm getting spun up right now.
I need to take a step back here and and throttled back.
I knew throttled back here cause I'm getting spun up.
So,
so with kids I got to look at it as you know what this is good cause cause I
know that's something that I,
it's in my nature that I can get spun up.
So with kids I got to relish that opportunity to say this is a training
opportunity for me to be outside of my comfort zone and just say,
Oh you know what?
I feel myself getting spun up.
I'm going to practice detaching and spinning down and not,
not reacting in a way that I might otherwise would have.
And I think it's a great,
it's a great tool there really for,
for me,
I think the,
when Jocko would since that in me,
and we've talked about a number of times when that's happened here on the
podcast that I was getting spun up,
you know,
we talked about,
previous,
uh,
in,
in previous podcasts about cancel the op and some of these things where I,
you know,
I just,
uh,
I would,
I would get fired relief and get angry and,
and you,
what most people would have done in that situation,
what I probably would have done to a subordinate leader is get is,
is gets spun up as well.
And like you yell at me now I'm going to yell at you but a little bit louder.
Exactly.
And how we're going to ramp up.
And it becomes like the battle of wills and,
and how you,
how you handled that exceptionally well with me was generally you would,
what you would never get spun up.
He would just be very calm and your response and you would ask questions or in
some cases you would just start chuckling like,
like laughing about it.
Like,
Hey man,
you get smart and not,
not in a way that it was condescending or like,
oh,
look at you.
You idiot.
Yeah.
It was in a way of going to laugh at people when they're getting mad.
It was in a wheel that,
hey man,
take it easy.
Yeah,
just take it easy.
And then you start laughing at anybody.
It was,
and then it just,
that was something that was,
what would you ask questions in a way that were,
hey,
well why,
why do you think this are those things?
That was powerful as well to me that wasn't,
it wasn't a like,
hey,
why are you doing this?
Or why won't you listen to me?
And it was,
that always allowed me to Kinda take a step back and recognize,
okay,
so,
so I think you,
you've got to make sure you see a red flag.
If somebody else they're getting spun up and they're really emotional,
you need to be unemotional and you need to,
you need to check your ego to do an end around,
I'd never see anybody do that before.
You do that exceptionally well a against me.
And uh,
and I learned a lot from that because I recognize like I got to do that better
and it never,
it just doesn't benefit you from getting spun up and angry.
And,
and I'll tell you one thing,
that's another little thing that I noticed that I do for sure is
if someone comes at me and they're super mad about something,
I can't just be a hundred percent calm.
Cause if,
if you come in the room at Uco,
chocolate is crap.
The we're getting told to do this thing over here,
this is total crap.
We shouldn't be told to do this.
And if I go Lafe just calm down,
it's not that big of a deal.
Like right there,
I've already taken it right.
Cause you're like,
well what are you talking about?
Not People.
I tried that with my wife Jenna.
At times it doesn't work very well.
The opposite,
what you have is you have to be,
you have to show some,
uh,
we'll call it a diminished reflection of the motion that they're showing.
You want to,
you want to take a little off of it,
but you don't owe my late for you serious.
They're telling us to do that.
Aw Man,
that's,
that's crap.
All right,
let's,
let's find out what's going on.
So now instead of being against you,
now all of a sudden I'm on your side.
I've calmed down a little bit.
I've brought you down a little bit,
but you at least recognize that I'm on your side.
Because if I just,
if I just say relief,
calm down,
getting mad is not going to help.
Won't like,
you're going to get even matter where if I say you need to think about what
they're saying,
no,
I need to join your side first.
Once I'm on your side,
now we can talk and we can move through the problem effectively.
So you might want to just show a little diminished reflection of the purr of,
you know,
if someone's really sad about something,
okay.
You know,
you can't just be like,
hey,
it's not that big of a deal.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
I got,
I got kids,
right?
I got,
I got teenage girls and you know,
they get sad about stuff.
Um,
and I can't just,
you know,
I've tried it before,
like,
don't worry about that.
It will mean nothing in three years I've done that.
I'm like,
by the time you graduated high school,
you don't even think about that anymore.
Stop.
How does that work?
It doesn't work good because you realize that that's the whole world to them.
So,
you know,
instead you've got to say,
aw man,
I can't believe that happened.
You know?
That's,
that's,
that's sad,
you know?
But the good thing is here's some good points about it and maybe,
you know what I mean?
So just don't be completely emotionless because then the person can't relate to
you.
And if they can't relate to you,
you're not gonna be able to talk about it.
If you can't talk about it,
you're not going to make any progress on the subject.
Careful of that one.
All right.
Want to hear more HDH in Vegas.
Did we talk about the HDH hands on one of the other podcasts?
Yeah,
we talked about it.
It's $100 on cast.
Vegas isn't a podcast 11,
if you want to hear about a markedly.
So [inaudible] is to Vegas.
We did have,
uh,
there were,
there were a couple of good stories.
Vegas and we,
you know,
we,
that was a crazy boondoggle chat but one of them that I,
I did,
uh,
remember well was we had this giant convoy of Humvees and uh,
we were coming up to a major intersection just off the Vegas trip.
Uh,
a red light cause we were just so everyone knows we're driving.
We drove the,
the Humvees to arrange to do work up in that area.
Uh,
there's an air force range knows Nellis Air Force Base.
So it was a Nellis range where they do training up there.
And we had taken the Humvees from one base on civilian roads to another base and
we'd spent the day training there and now it was time to come back to base.
And we're back on civilian roads again in a,
in a convoy of Humvees.
What,
five trucks?
Probably.
So five Humvees.
And we had done a drill where we had the,
we,
I was always big on you train how you fight,
right?
So that means if we're driving home fees,
guess what we're doing?
We're mounting weapons.
We're going to,
we're going to be ready to get after it if we have to.
Not that we're gonna have to get after it in Vegas,
but we're going to,
we're going to test things because if you're not used to swing that gun around,
up in the up in the Turret,
then you're not used to it.
So you've got a practice.
So we were basically in,
in full kind of kit.
I think we actually had the whole task in us.
I think we had like eight or 10 humvees.
It was,
it was,
it was a big,
big tomboy.
But,
uh,
yeah,
so we come up to it.
We're coming up to a red light.
The red light starts to turn yellow and the lead,
the lead navigator.
Um,
yeah,
this is a major intersection,
you know,
two,
four lane roads that are coming up,
coming up to,
uh,
he's,
he gives the command below,
through,
which means that a,
we're just,
if you get your an ambush and people are shooting at you and you're just going
to keep rolling and he says blow through.
So we literally have the entire convoy behind him,
like running this red light and a major,
major intersection.
I was like,
we're going to be standing tall off the Abu [inaudible].
We don't want to do that because in,
in like an Iraqi,
you wouldn't stop at a red light or you wouldn't stop at a stop sign.
You,
you know,
you obviously the lead vehicle would check close enough and then you,
you're traveling really tight and you make sure there's no cars coming.
But yeah,
you're just going to blow through.
You're not going to stop.
And so that,
yeah,
the call came out to blow through,
which we're going to get in trouble for that it would have been a fight.
Well,
luckily we had some heads up drivers that stopped at the,
at the,
their green and,
and saw us coming,
or maybe they were intimidated by guys with 50 cal machine guns and the Turret.
But,
uh,
definitely,
you know,
that's one of those things where it's hard for guys to turn it off sometimes.
And then when you're,
when you're doing tactical driving on the range as if you were in a combat
scenario and all of a sudden you're on the street again,
this is hard.
I should have been said,
okay guys,
we're going back on swing roads.
Stand down.
You know what I mean?
I should have said that,
but I didn't say that because I'm dumb and I,
you know,
we,
we made the assumption,
which turned out to be false,
that people would automatically know that and they didn't.
So we had to tighten that up.
But,
uh,
that was just one lesson learned from our,
our biggest trick that was shenanigans.
These good times.
I'm surprised I didn't get in more trouble for that.
One of the one a year guys,
we were in a,
he was a designated driver wearing a navy fan and we go from one place,
we knew someone and we were out in town and we went from there to downtown to go
to know the bars.
Right in Vegas we're pulling into a parking garage and you know how they have
that metal pipe that says,
you know,
six foot,
two inch clearance or whatever the clearance was.
It was a very low parking garage.
So he's got this big Navy van.
We come in and we kind of hit that.
And I'm,
I'm sitting in the back at,
and you know what,
this is a classic example of a decentralized command.
I'm not gonna step on the toes.
The guys,
the designated driver,
I wasn't drinking.
I had a few drinks or whatever,
but I wasn't definitely wasn't intoxicated.
And,
but I see,
oh,
like I look out and see what we,
we kind of hit that thing.
And so we go around the corner and then we start to actually enter the parking
garage.
And as we go underneath the first concrete beam,
the,
it's,
you can hear it with scrapes against the ceiling,
but it scrapes hard and the vehicle comes to a stop.
And what does the driver do again?
This is the designated driver.
What does he do?
He starts pressing down the gas.
He's just going to power through this.
I'm in the back.
I go,
dude,
blow through.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you doing?
Stop.
What are you going to rip the roof off of the vehicle?
Like back out here in leave music?
Well,
we photo made mood.
Oh Man.
One,
one Gig,
a team guy.
Shenanigans that we were talking about was me,
you and the Delta commander.
Dell platoon commander.
Rolling.
Rolling up to Santa Barbara.
I think you actually came up to me and said,
tenacious.
Tenacious D.
Yeah.
So for those of you may not know,
Jocko is a huge tenacious d fan,
the d and I think that that's how it came out.
You're like the d there in Santa Barbara.
Let's go.
Road trip,
road trip,
road Gig,
no Gig.
So we jumped in.
Yeah.
Of all the things that you gave me,
you gave me a copy of about face by David Hackworth.
When,
when,
when we were working together to you brazer a at the end of our art,
our tour together.
And you gave me the,
this set to the,
of the DVDs to tenacious d and the dove tiggers.
So that's the dichotomy of leadership right there.
Hackworth about faced that tenacious d.
So we found out tenacious d was having a,
having a concert up in Santa Barbara,
you know,
were all stationed here at San Diego and,
and we jumped in Jockos dodge grand,
1997 Dodge Grand Caravan,
1997 a lot of people just called it the pimp wagon because it was hard to keep
the ladies off when you're rolling.
And this is the window was tape shot on the driver's side.
It's too rigorous.
Taped,
shut harder.
You weren't getting in there.
Nothing thing was shut because a little electrical thing broke.
So we're uh,
we're,
we're cheap bastard so we're not going to spend the night up there.
I think we actually had work to do maybe the next day.
So we jumped,
we jumped in the van.
Jock,
I think you drove up there.
We rock out to tenacious d concert in Santa Barbara.
We uh,
we bought Jocko a tee shirt to still got it.
The Sasquatch is real.
And I remember driving back at about,
there's about three o'clock in the morning.
We were like passing through Camp Pendleton as kind of where our ranges are
there.
As,
as on the way back down,
we'll just acapella singing to every tenacious d zone that we,
we knew by heart.
We're going to make a new band.
It's going to be called Acappella.
Capello d
that was a good time.
Yeah,
that was a
pretty fun.
All right.
Tenacious d
what are your daily non negotiable habits?
Wave Babin my daily non negotiable habits use the odd one who,
uh,
asleep and about 10 30,
10:30 AM and style,
just a,
he's some donuts.
Listen,
I mean,
I,
I th th at the end of the day,
just when he goes freedom,
it's a mantra that I learned from you and that it's,
it just absolutely true.
And if you gotta,
um,
you gotta get up in the morning to workout on the,
on the,
there's some days I frankly,
I can't do that because life gets in the way,
whether I'm,
if I'm traveling or,
uh,
my,
my kid wakes up early and I know I've been out of town and my wife wants to get
a workout in before the day starts.
So I've taken the kids so she can do that and we can,
we can rotate out,
you know,
so,
so I can't tell you that always happens.
Um,
but you gotta get up early,
you got to work out and you have to,
you have to prioritize and eschewed and and having that checklist that you put
together the night before about what you want to do a and what's important is,
is absolute critical.
Otherwise you lose it.
And you know,
for me and Jocko and for all of us at our team on echelon front like it,
it's when we get away from the things that we talk about the people,
we're human beings like everybody else and we can get pulled in different
directions.
When we get away from those things,
it doesn't work.
They start to fall apart.
You lose,
you lose track of where the priorities are.
If I can't regularly detach,
that's something that I have to really focus on to do is is,
is to regularly detached.
If I'm grinding on something for two or three or four hours at a time,
sometimes it's easy to miss other things that are,
that are coming up.
I got to make sure I pull away from things,
kind of it kind of think about the prior prioritize.
Nice,
cute piece,
figured out,
you know,
if I need to reprioritize and,
and so I don't get target fixating on one thing and,
and,
and keep going.
But,
uh,
I think for me,
what I want to do is I try to make time to spend time with my family as much as
I can as well.
And obviously there's a,
there's a,
there's a lot of work to do.
There always is.
Um,
and uh,
and it's,
you know,
those things.
Um,
the,
when,
when I could stay consistent on getting up early in the morning,
getting a workout in,
you know,
stay focused on our list that I have from the night before that I'm falling
through all of the things that you talk about.
Uh,
that's,
I,
I'm,
I'm performing better than I ever do to you.
When it works,
at the end of the day,
there's what works and what doesn't work.
That's how you win.
Check.
Tell us about a time you were annoyed with Jocko or his intensity.
Annoyed with Jocko or his intensity.
Um,
you know what,
we,
uh,
we got along pretty damn well together and uh,
and I think,
uh,
there's not a,
there's not really any time that comes to mind that I was annoyed by you except
for maybe,
you know what,
what I mentioned earlier,
right?
When the times when initially when we're working together and you're looking
over my shoulder and telling me to do like,
we should do this way,
let's,
let's plan it like that.
That I definitely got got annoyed from that time when I felt like I want to run
my,
you know,
everyone's trying to tell me what to do here.
And jock was looking over my shoulder.
I want to run,
run my team just as I earlier.
Um,
and,
and I didn't realize until later like what you are doing,
you're like,
hey,
you're,
you're passing,
you're passing on a lot of great information.
And I see that all the time actually with people because if I could have
detached from that situation,
I would recognize like,
Hey,
I'm a new Pataki manner.
I've never been at a tick manner.
Jocko was just doubled their commander.
He had a highly successful particular manner tour.
He had historic deployment.
We did a whole bunch operations.
Uh,
and he's got a ton of lessons learned.
So what an amazing opportunity to learn everything from him.
But that's not the way you approach it,
right?
It's like an ego.
My Ego,
and I see it all the time.
There was a,
there was a leader,
a leader I was dealing with were,
I was talking to a member of the board,
um,
for this particular leader who was constantly bucking against the,
you know,
this guys.
And it was,
it's amazing to me though to see like,
hey,
the,
the CEO of this company who's pushing back in September the board,
like,
he should be so thankful that the member of the board has,
who's got massive amounts of experience.
Extraordinary success is there to mentor and train them.
And yet he doesn't want to listen to that guy.
I want to do it myself.
You're always over my shoulder.
Instead of being like,
hey man,
open up the legal pad.
Let's take some notes here.
I'm going to,
I want to pick your brain for everything.
I want to,
you know,
it's,
and,
and I think just recognize if you're feeling that way and you're frustrated
with,
with somebody who's,
uh,
looking over your shoulder,
then then you need to take advantage of the situation and learn from them.
Uh,
and certainly build up,
trust the bow.
The way to get out of that situation is to build up trust that show that you,
you're learning,
you're growing and,
and that you don't need someone to look over your shoulder every second.
And usually that comes even after we got forward and you just unleashed us on
the battlefield,
I would always come to you and be like,
Hey Jackie,
what do you think about this?
We're going to do this situation.
I wasn't looking to you to tell me what to do,
uh,
but I was running things by you.
And we do that all the time.
Now that's not in front.
I called Jocko up and say,
hey,
here's what's going on.
I'm working with this leader.
Uh,
you do the same.
I mean we,
we talk about these things all the time and that it's actually that,
what's interesting about that is that in the last six months,
that idea has really become formalized in the tank,
which is where we take the companies that we're working with and we,
whoever's working specifically with,
with a specific company on the ground is coming back to the tank,
all,
all the echelon front team.
And we get on the call or the Skype or the conference room and we'd go through
all the issues that all these different companies are happening and that's where
we solve the problems is in the tank.
So that way we get everyone's input.
And not only do we give the best solution to the client,
we also all learned from it so that we have that solution in our heads.
So it'd be we all get stronger and better.
So that's,
that's one of the evolutions and national on front that's pretty awesome to see
is what started off as just like how we would run to you.
Bruiser,
which is,
hey,
we're going to bounce ideas off each other and hey,
I don't know how to solve this problem to you or hey,
I don't know how to do this operation to you or this is what I think,
what do you think?
Which is the way a team should work together and now what we do is we get to do
that for other companies.
Use the same brainpower,
you use the same methodology and it's,
it's awesome to do and it's awesome to see.
It is awesome.
The tank.
Yeah,
getting in the tank.
Uh,
all right,
life.
You were,
for those of you who don't know,
life was a ship driver for how many years before.
So me didn't get picked up for seal teams right out road.
Didn't get picked up for buds right out of the Naval Academy.
So he had to go to a ship.
Here's a question about,
not about that specifically,
but a life.
What are your thoughts on a ship's captain?
Being relieved of command and what to do if you are involved.
And he would like to know from the ship's captains perspective that is being
relieved because of the mistakes of your crew or if you're in the crew and the
captain's getting real,
getting relieved even though you made the mistakes.
What are you,
what are your perspectives on that?
Well,
look,
just to give people some background on that.
I know I've talked about my background in podcast 11,
but,
but it was,
I never wanted to be a shift job.
I wanted to be a seal.
That's why I went to the Naval Academy.
Uh,
I got thrust in that position.
Looking back on it.
It was,
it was an amazing opportunity for me as a young man to have to be in those
leadership positions.
And I enjoyed my time on the ship is a warship cost to build billion,
couple of billion dollars.
Crazy.
So you're,
you're,
sometimes you're the guy,
right?
You're a lieutenant JG on the bridge of a $2 billion ship and you're in charge
of all,
when you're,
when you're the officer of the deck that you're the guy in charge,
the captain's asleep in his cabin and he's got all full,
full faith and trust in you and you're running the ship.
And so there's the question right there.
Sometimes the captain,
the ship asleep in the cabin and he runs the [inaudible] and the crew runs the
ship aground,
the captain gets fired.
What do you think about that?
That is the navy way.
It's uh,
it's always been that way.
Uh,
and uh,
I think it's 100% correct because there are no bad teams,
only bad leaders.
And I think that if you have,
um,
even if the captain wasn't in direct responsibility,
it's his job to train that team.
It's his job to mentor that team.
And if he's got questions about whether or not somebody is,
uh,
has the capability to do that job,
then,
then they shouldn't be in that position.
It's up,
it's up,
it's up to the captain now.
The captain can be everywhere at once.
So it's decentralized command.
He has to rely on his leaders.
But,
uh,
it's,
um,
it's definitely,
uh,
I think ultimately the,
the,
the captain is responsible and that's really what makes ownership stuff.
A client asks me a question yesterday,
uh,
have you ever sent anyone to do something that they weren't ready to do?
And I thought about it for a minute,
and the first thought was,
well,
of course then the second thought was,
no,
the real answer is it's gray area.
Right?
Did I ever send somebody to do something that they weren't 100%.
If I put this quantification on 100% ready for it,
all the time,
uh,
how often did I send somebody to do something that they weren't capable of
doing?
The answer is zero.
In other words,
if you weren't capable of doing this,
and I didn't trust that you could make
it happen,
I wasn't gonna let you do it.
That'd be irresponsible for me as a leader to let a subordinate go and do
something that they're not ready to do.
That's it.
Period.
Or they're not 100% ready to do,
are there?
No,
not,
not 100% but they're not capable of doing.
But I mean when we first got to Ramadi in your mind,
you probably weren't a hundred percent ready to go out there and execute.
And particularly because we've had training for a mission with just seals,
you know,
for,
for roll-up assaults or direct action raids,
you know,
at nighttime and all of a sudden we're shifting to daytime counterinsurgency
operations,
working with Iraqi soldiers.
Completely different mission.
Yeah.
Broken up in all these different units.
We hadn't trained,
we haven't trained like that in a violent war zone by the way.
But I,
you know,
I had trust that you were completely competent and capable of doing that.
And if I didn't think that and I didn't think you were competent or I didn't
think you were capable,
then I would be a bad leader if I said,
yeah,
go ahead and go to go do that.
And,
and then I answered the question further to this client.
I said there was two people from tasking at bruiser that didn't go on deployment
with us because they weren't capable of doing that job.
So yes,
you as a leader,
you're responsible.
I was thinking about this.
There's been times where navy ships have run aground and the captain wasn't even
on board.
He had flown to somewhere to go do a meeting somewhere.
The ship runs aground.
Guess what?
Still getting fired because you left someone in charge that you left that team.
You didn't train them well enough,
and you can make all the excuses you want.
I wasn't there.
Yeah.
Well guess what?
You're still getting fired because you were responsible for that team.
So I think part of that too is the understanding.
You know what?
No bad teams,
only bad leaders.
The chapter two we wrote extreme ownership is about the part of that is,
I have seen some people misinterpret that,
right?
To say,
well,
I'll get a better leader.
So the team's not good.
That's not an excuse.
So when we're talking about leadership,
we're talking about leaders at every level of the organization.
So,
so,
you know,
if you're,
if you're a department head on that ship or a division officer,
a division chief,
and you say,
Oh,
I've got a bad,
I got a bad commanding officer,
it's all the commanding officers fall.
Our ship doesn't,
does it perform the way it should?
Whatever your team is,
that's not an excuse you.
You got to do your utmost to get your team ready to train others around you,
uh,
and,
and lead that team as much as you possibly can.
And you don't have to be the senior guy in charge and office.
Some of the best units we work with,
and we're part of the senior guy,
may not,
he may have been the guy driving the operations,
but he allowed his leaders to go out and execute and,
and make it happen.
So leadership,
we're talking,
we're talking to leaders at every level,
the organization.
It's not an excuse to put the blame on the boss.
Uh,
you gotta step up.
You got to lead and own your team,
solve problems,
get better,
learn from mistakes and make it happen.
What does it mean when a ship runs aground mean,
literally hits dirt?
Oh,
it's true.
Well,
and in this case,
we're talking about ship collisions.
So running to ground is one thing.
Uh,
the,
um,
you know,
and there's an org,
there is an argument to be said like,
because some of our greatest leaders like,
uh,
Adam wrote fleet,
Admiral Chester Nimitz who was the hero,
the Pacific war was the,
quoted him,
you know,
on this,
uh,
on this Badass.
Previously,
he was the commander in chief of all US forces in the Pacific.
So he was,
he was the,
the,
the person responsible for the entire war effort against the Japanese in World
War II.
And that victory,
uh,
a massive effort,
obviously in an extraordinary turnaround,
uh,
from,
from disaster to two victory.
He actually ran the ship aground as,
as a,
as a junior officer.
So,
so there's,
you know,
there's an argument to be made that there is no fee.
You know,
the flawless performance.
It doesn't exist and people make mistakes.
You can learn from it.
Um,
you know,
as far as ships running around,
um,
you know,
that,
that's one thing I think,
you know,
you can make a care of a careful evaluation.
What we're talking about here that is specifically say ship collisions and uh,
you know,
those,
those should not happen that just,
that should not happen.
I understand how easily that can happen cause it,
there's a,
these are huge machines that go very fast and you're out on the ocean with
other,
other ships that are moving around and there's a whole lot of dangerous things.
Those big ships takes miles to stop them.
Like even if you see it,
you go,
okay,
hit all full breaks right now.
It doesn't matter.
You're still going to hit.
Absolutely.
You know,
you're going to get hit for like 10 minutes.
Yup.
You know,
if you can't stop it,
just brace for impact.
Yeah.
But,
but if you've got,
you've got the right team in place,
they know what they're doing,
you know,
there,
there's all kinds of safe,
safe guards in place.
And if that team's properly trained,
like that should not happen.
It shouldn't.
I,
it's like you should be able to,
the airplane should land safely.
All the horrible things that could go wrong when you're flying in an airplane
and landing in a crazy airport like JFK or lax Hong Kong.
Yeah,
that's a doozy.
So those,
those kinds of things that are crazy.
So,
but there's a lot of things to go wrong,
but if it's done properly and safeguards are in place,
you're going to,
you're going to be fine.
So,
so,
but there's again,
it,
it doesn't mean that we expect flawless performance,
that no one's ever going to make mistakes.
I think if a mistake isn't that bad,
it should be forgiven.
But there isn't.
There just isn't an excuse of like,
well,
it wasn't me.
Somebody else on my team did it.
That's the opposite extreme in ownership.
It doesn't work.
That was the word check.
Next.
This is really,
well I guess,
yeah,
I guess it is for life.
I heard you say it is important to think I heard Jocko say this too.
How do you think meaning,
how do you talk to yourself?
Do you ask yourself questions?
Do you think by talking to others,
what do you believe is the most valuable method for becoming a clear thinker and
communicator?
That's a deep question.
I actually think it's pretty easy to answer.
It is easy answer.
I think I can answer in one word.
Go Detach.
That's that's,
that's how I think.
You can't,
you got to step out.
You got to step back mentally.
You've got to step back,
look at what's going on and think of and that's where you can think about it.
That's where you can figure out what's going on.
If you can do that,
you're there.
If you can't do it,
you don't even know you're not doing it.
That's the problem.
When you're not detached,
you don't even know you're not detached,
you're in the storm and you don't even it.
That's a
job for,
that's exactly right,
but I think you know for people that maybe don't fully understand what that
means.
Right.
This this idea of the tasks of which you've obviously talked a lot about on
hearing,
which is such a key thing for decision making.
It's the,
the,
I think the key thing there is,
is to make sure that you're not,
you're not clouded by this emotional attachment to plans,
which we often talk about with our leaders in the seal teams.
I'm emotionally invested in a plan that I came up with.
I spent hours or days or weeks or months,
you know,
in involved in,
uh,
and I want that to succeed,
of course,
but,
but is that,
you know,
I got to have that realistic assessment.
And that's what the detachment really requires,
is that you pull yourself not just physically away out of the weeds or to say,
okay,
let me think about this and the strategic picture.
But you really,
you take away that emotional investment that you have to maybe even whether it's
a plant,
sometimes it's a team member as well.
And if you have,
you know,
someone that you just have a close relationship with that you,
whether they're a relative of yours or you've had a longstanding relationship
with and that maybe you've gotten too close to them and you can't see that,
that you know,
they become more important than the mission and they're dragging the rest of the
team down.
You're not making the call either tightened them up or let them go with that.
That's the right case.
So I think what that really requires is you got to emotionally pulled back.
It's,
it's a,
it's a mental thing to,
to really have a brutally honest assessment of the situation.
Uh,
that's,
that's independent from any kind of a previous bias that you might've had.
That's interesting there because even if you know,
like,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to detach.
Oh,
it's not that easy.
Yeah.
Like go through the motions.
You can't be like,
Hey,
I'm going to detach them detached right now.
Meanwhile,
you're just,
like I said,
clouded by the emotional part that you're like kind of one foot in and
emotionally so you're technically not detached.
So it doesn't work.
You know what else is a good way to think is to listen.
Listen to what people are saying.
I've been thinking about how more,
how he said,
if you listen,
you know twice as much,
you know everything that you know and you know everything that the other guy
knows,
that's a great,
that's a great thing.
But if you're sitting in a,
in a conversation,
I mean from a business perspective,
if you're in a meeting and,
and there's a conversation going on,
if you're in the conversation,
you're talking and you're adding your piece,
well then you're,
you're not detached,
you're in it.
But if you sit back and you listen and you hear what's going on,
you can assemble,
you know?
Fobts better.
So,
all right,
next.
When can we expect any books to come out by either of you and what are they
going to be like?
Extreme ownership or way of the warrior kid.
So I also had a book out called discipline equals freedom.
It's a field manual by the way.
Sure.
You familiar with field manual Naco you claim to be familiar with field manual
and his favorite kind of manual.
Okay.
Way The warrior kid too is coming out in April.
It's called Mark's mission.
And we are in the process writing,
Leif Babin.
Tell me about that.
Yes,
we are.
We're getting after a second book right now.
It's a follow on book,
two extreme ownership and a,
I'm super excited about.
It's,
it's a,
it's going to be in the same format when we talk about combat combat lessons
learned on the battlefield or in training and then a principal and then as
application of the business squirreled,
uh,
and the same in the same format as extreme ownership.
And what it really is,
is it's to answer all of the questions and difficulties that people have from
applying the principles.
We get these common questions all the time.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm having this issue and okay,
you said taking ownership here,
but,
uh,
what does that really mean and error?
How do I apply a cover moved,
you know,
to my team.
Uh,
these,
uh,
it's going to dive much deeper into that.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's going to be also gonna be coming out fall of 2018.
How do you feel about writing a sequel?
It's a,
it's not a sequel.
It's going to be a standalone book on its own.
It's going to be good.
Okay.
I,
I think it's nerve wracking because,
you know what,
have you ever seen the movie jaws?
Yes.
That's one of my favorite movies.
Have you ever seen the movie jaws too?
Yes,
we got issues with jaws too.
We got issues and this is what I think.
So I think,
again,
I'll call it luck,
maybe not,
but I call it luck.
Luckily for us,
this book has sold really well that if we would've written a sequel a year after
this book came out,
it would have been jaws too,
to be honest with you.
But luckily during,
because now it's been two years since this came out.
So we've had,
uh,
and,
and by the way,
a followup year,
if we were to re released a book,
if the is going released another book,
released another book,
you will,
we'll pay you more money.
That's what they do.
They want you to really start a book.
Now we got some hype from this book,
we'll get another one out there and life.
And I were like,
well no,
not right now.
Just stop and we'll let time we write another book.
Well I did write another book,
but they're not the same.
Right.
We don't want,
we want,
we don't want to make jaws too.
So we let time go.
And guess what we were doing all the time that we,
that we had passed,
right?
We weren't sitting around.
No,
we were working with more companies.
We're working with more military units.
We were working with police were working firefighters,
we were having the muster,
we were learning more and more lessons.
And we were getting feedback from this book and saying,
okay,
I see some threads.
And at first it was one little thread and there was another little thread and
now all of a sudden all those threads come together and you get something,
you get,
you get a fabric.
And that's what we waited for is let's get something that is a woven fabric is
gonna be strong.
Like Calphalon.
So the next book that we got coming out,
I disagree with you that it's a standalone book.
I don't think it's a standalone book.
Are you going to retract your statement?
I'm gonna give you a chance.
You should I do check my statement because,
because it is,
I mean,
the new book,
I thought you were setting me up for a,
uh,
an ambush them.
No,
no.
It's,
I'm sure can read the new book
on you're on its own,
but you shouldn't,
you should read extreme ownership first and then you read the new book and when
you read a new book,
it's going to,
again,
all those threads are going to weave together and,
and,
and
they're going to be the perfect,
it's going to be,
they're going to compliment each other.
Amazing.
An amazing way.
I think that's in that and that method or an for from that perspective.
Absolutely.
I think absolutely it is.
It is a sequel net perspective.
It,
it will be written in a way that,
that you can read it as a standalone book for,
for sure.
Uh,
it will certainly reference,
uh,
you know,
the things that we talked about in extreme ownership and the foundational
principles of home would say that that's a written,
I think there are a few exceptions.
Don't do your jaws analogy and excellent.
I mean,
I can think that Indiana Jones and the temple of Doom Terminator Terminator two
Judgment Day,
but it doesn't have a lot to do with how you said,
hey,
let's wait a little bit.
Yeah,
that's true.
Unless the whole story that you going to dust the difference.
Cause if you just,
Oh,
we had a hit movie.
Make another one.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's a good title.
Jaws wasn't hit.
Let's make another one.
We'll call it jaws to yeah.
If they would've waited,
like terminate,
they waited at what,
eight years or so,
then it's like,
okay,
a lot of things are updated,
a lot of new stuff.
They figured it out and it's like you were saying that boom terminated two just
as good aliens,
aliens.
The first movie was that pretty quick afterwards,
the second movie aliens crossed the first movie.
Really?
Eh,
I,
to be totally honest,
it's a gamble though.
No,
I actually,
I don't know cause I'm,
I'm halfway,
a little bit more than halfway done with my writing part,
right before we start editing each other.
I think,
I think we might have an,
uh,
a SQL that's better.
I Dunno,
I have a suspicion that this equals better,
possibly better.
So I think so too.
It's been super fun to write know as we're doing a,
I think,
as you said,
are our knowledge is so much more now.
I mean,
we,
our knowledge of the business world was,
was,
you know,
we,
we'd been working for a couple of,
you know,
two or three years in the business world at that point.
Uh,
but,
but now we've got double more than double that and yeah,
and the region expansion of,
of,
of what we've been doing since the release of extreme ownership is it's a
hundred x what we were doing previously.
So,
uh,
that's just given us,
it's been a massive education and our knowledge of how to apply these things
across the spectrum,
yeah.
Is Incredibly,
um,
uh,
so much,
so much deeper than than it was previously.
And,
and um,
I'm,
I'm excited about it.
Yeah.
It's going to be good.
Next question is how long does it take to prepare for a muster?
And when,
when we read this question earlier,
I thought it was the person asking how long it would take this individual,
me or whoever,
uh,
a person out in the world to get ready to go to the muster.
Oh yeah.
And the answer to that is it doesn't take you any time.
You just,
I mean,
you should read extreme ownership for sure,
but there's no,
like big physical,
there's physical things that you do with the muster,
but they're scaled that anybody can do them.
So it's really,
you don't need to do any major preparation other than put your ego in check.
I didn't think it's preparation you need is,
is to look at yourself in the mirror and,
and write down that,
that where you're weakest and where you need to work.
I mean,
that's what we want to talk about it.
I don't care where you're doing great.
We're not there to patch on the back.
We want to care like where you can get better and everyone can get better.
Certainly you can prove all the time and I think that's what you need to do.
I thought this question was about how we prepped for the muster,
which is it's always about,
which is substantial always about life.
It's all about me all the time.
It's,
it's,
it is a ton of work to prepare for the monster,
but it's fun.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's,
it's great.
We do it.
A random question.
In your experience,
have you had or do you see high injury rates in Jujitsu?
Want to start rolling again but don't want to disrupt progress on the Barbell,
Barb?
Oh yeah,
sure.
Well,
it's possible.
I am being a weak suck,
although not probable
risk assessment.
What do you think?
Can you get injured in Jujitsu?
Yes.
Yeah.
Look,
just like he can injured.
Even been injured,
playing basketball.
She,
you'll get injured playing basketball quicker than you did two events as far as
it goes.
Yeah,
I will.
I the the,
the key part about this question for me is you want to keep making progress on
the Barbell,
right?
Yeah.
So you want to keep getting stronger.
That's cool.
I want you to be stronger,
but if you're super strong,
you didn't know how to fight.
I got nothing for you.
Yeah.
That's a deeper thing too.
And keep this in mind though,
and this goes for any it physical activity.
Like if your goal physically is this thing and then you start going hard in
another direction,
it could very well take away from you.
You're not going to reach your maximum potential as a weightlifter if you're
doing Jujitsu for sure.
Swimming or swimming or anything else about ever.
Yeah.
You got to find a balance.
But I mean,
what's the most important?
What's a more important skill to have?
Be able to snatch big weight or be able to defend yourself in a street fight.
Hey,
the snatching big weight's going to help you defend yourself.
We appreciate that we're fans.
Yeah.
But prioritize now what's interesting is on a daily basis,
I always work out,
but I don't always do Jujitsu because you can't,
you need,
you need someone to train with.
You know what I mean?
Like he need somebody to do Jujitsu with you,
can't you just,
you're by yourself.
So sometimes you don't have anyone to train with.
Look,
I think from my perspective as a,
as a white belt,
it's,
uh,
I,
I've trained enough,
if you've gotta be getting close to that Blue Bouche will,
uh,
I got a lot,
lot more work to do.
Certainly a lot more to it.
It's not up to him and you guys.
Yeah,
that's true.
You guys have inspired me.
I'm trying to turn it hard.
Got A,
got a great place.
I'm turning down in Texas now.
John John Machado.
Austin's awesome.
Yeah.
Todd white collar,
white sauce today.
If you're the type of people that train in there,
I mean,
it's,
and that's,
that's what I like about it.
That's that.
That's the same thing that the place I tried to New York,
it's just that to me has,
uh,
I think if you're constantly getting injured all the time,
like you're not training with the right people
and you're not training in the,
in the right manner of something that I learned years ago.
And when I was on the boxing team,
the Naval Academy,
me and my buddies,
you know,
who were kind of scrubs,
we didn't travel with the team,
but we just beat the piss out of each other every,
every day.
And no one could breathe out of their nose at.
Everyone had black eyes.
And he watched the guy who was the guys who were really skilled.
They smart,
but they were working on form.
There were,
you know,
they,
they weren't just knocking each other's heads off every punch,
every time,
you know,
every single day.
And I think that's,
that's where you have to,
it's great to train hard,
but I think you need to train smart and I think you,
you need to,
the biggest thing,
I'm guessing this person is probably hasn't trained that much so that they,
they spin out Dave Burke and I were just rolling here at victory last night.
And uh,
I was,
uh,
I was telling,
telling Dave,
you know,
Dave,
he's made some progress,
has been training out in Virginia.
I was like,
cool man,
you're doing good.
But he's,
he gets so amped up that he can't detach so he can't detach because he's,
he's gets so amped up and it's,
I realized I used to just be in that I've trained enough now,
I still might be the white belts.
She,
but I've trained it enough now to know that,
uh,
that I've got,
I've got to the throttle that back.
Cause it's,
you get so focused,
right.
I'm going to focus on my one little white built American.
I'm trying to get it,
you know,
or arm bar versus versus like,
no,
detach and think for this looks like four or five
with him.
Yeah,
we did like,
yeah.
So he,
it was funny because we were rolling around it.
I mean,
he is,
uh,
and at one point I'm like laughing at him because he's literally like
that,
that kind of briefly like Dave [inaudible] was like,
you know,
when you breathe,
when you feel,
hear somebody breathing hard like that,
typically it's like when you're there,
right in your ear,
so it's,
it sounds way more intense.
They,
what about the tie?
It could have been also because I had a little,
little,
little elbow pressure will go up to the time period when you're like kind of
starting Jujitsu and Dave Burke might be in this situation right now.
It's,
it's the very early end Jujitsu where in your mind you think like,
you know what,
like I'll be able to,
I think I'll be able to get like Jocko,
right?
Like I'll be like,
hey man,
I evict.
They let him some little move and they're like,
Oh,
if I throw this Ajiaco at the right time at this black belt,
the right time won't be able to get them.
You know what I'm saying?
For sure I had with Dean one time.
Yeah.
I mean what I,
when you're amped up to that level though,
you know,
and yeah,
you with your thinking that like no one can tap me or,
and I don't think Dave's is in that and that mode,
he's learned enough maybe to be,
be beyond that.
But it's,
it's when you're that amped up,
your chances of,
of getting injured or way worse,
just more significant.
It's why,
you know,
if you see a brand new white belt coming,
I'd much rather roll with Brown belts and purpose blue,
even though I know they're gonna,
you know,
they're going to get the best of me.
Uh,
I have a much less chance of getting injured then just the death match with some
white belt who's,
you know,
who doesn't even know,
anything.
And,
and,
and so I think
you've gotta be smart about who you trained with.
And that's what I love about,
you know,
uh,
genres up,
Machado Austin with,
with Todd white does guys,
they're,
they're there,
they're super,
you know,
they're very knowledgeable.
They pass on stuff with her humble,
just,
just like,
just like folks here if victory.
I mean it,
it's,
uh,
and I think when you're training with the right people,
they're like,
oh,
cool,
you got,
you got me in an arm bar.
You've got to know that choke was great.
Show me how to do that.
And it's,
it's,
uh,
but it's a humble learning environment where,
you know,
you're not there to injure people,
you're not there to get hurt.
And I think it's sure you're going to get tweaks and,
and bumps and bruises,
but I think there's,
you know,
if you're training smartly and training to learn,
then a,
the chance of getting injured,
the probability is much less.
My boy,
Todd [inaudible],
Todd white,
he's like old school Jiujitsu guy and he,
me and him were on the circuit.
Burke,
the competence to back in the day,
he was La John Jacques Guy.
And,
and he,
by the way,
he listens to the podcast by the way.
La Payments were fully,
yeah,
they were back in the day.
All right.
Um,
in addition to that,
the Jujitsu,
what even like,
I wouldn't want to paint the picture of that.
Like all white belts are going to increase your chance of injury.
It's a,
it's kind of a specific type of person that will increase your chance of injury
and that's like a guy who's strong may or may not have like this eagle where you
can't tell me and I'm going to try to kick you every single time.
For sure.
And he,
he has like an element of like legitimate strength lettuces.
So you've got to put all those together.
Like you go into a typical gym,
all,
you take all the white belt,
you may not even have a guy like that.
That's true.
The probability of a guy being like that is pretty low.
I'm not saying
there might be higher products,
pretty low.
Depends on what the changes that though,
in my opinion,
what changes is the,
is the black belt instructor like someone's like,
Oh,
you want to get tough with that guy over there?
We'll let,
let me,
I'm going to impose some humility on you.
It's called regulation.
It has to be,
yeah.
Which is yet another factor that kind of contributes to the overall safety of
it.
So,
and I'm not saying low,
like they're rare and nothing like that.
What I'm saying,
if you take a just,
I don't know,
some random class,
uh,
new white belt spazzy strong maybe may or may not be young with like a huge ego.
Maybe one guy,
maybe you won't get a class full of though.
So your day to day rolling is,
is pretty safe.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You do need to pick your training partners carefully for sure.
But to this guy though.
[inaudible] I mean,
look back when I go way back,
I think I probably knew echo even before,
before you did Jacqueline in our a surface warfare days are good,
good Fred cake nuts who's a mutual friend and,
and others that we've uh,
kicked me,
we work with.
In fact,
echo was,
you were,
he was a bouncer downtown before I'd,
everyone knows cause he talks about he had to put up with all our shenanigans in
trouble.
Yes.
But I remember
coming in here and training it victory and echo was a blue belt and showing me
and cake nuts like some moves and,
and,
and because I kind of had this mentality of the guy who asked this question of
like,
you know,
you might get injured and I was focused on other things and I trained you're all
the time.
And a lot of times I'd be here to work out and I,
I do stand up,
uh,
and I would never,
I never trained Jujitsu.
Like I should have never stuck with it consistently didn't have the discipline
to do that.
Uh,
for whatever reason,
I get pulled in different directions and you know,
here we are 10 or 12 years later and echoes of Brown belt.
He knocking on the door of a,
I'm getting his black belt and I'm still a white belt.
What doors he knocking on?
I'm not knocking on door getting knocked on this matter.
I don't think about their silence out there,
so don't be that guy.
I think,
uh,
I would make the time to train pretty good.
So,
yeah,
for sure.
All right.
Losing a teammate,
both military and civilian civilian world happens.
How do you assist and promote healing and growth within a team that has lost a
pivotal member?
What do you do when the emotional toll leaves your guys' unfocused and is
creating unacceptable risks?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I've talked about this,
this before and I think obviously in this can happen,
this is part of life is death and people are gonna die and you obviously we're
all going to deal with,
they're all going to face it at some time.
You know,
work environment.
How do you deal with it?
One of the things that I always say is get back to work,
right?
You're,
yes,
you're going to mourn.
Yes,
you're going to have your memorial services,
and then you got to get back to work.
And I think if you let people,
if you give them too much time off,
if you let them sit around,
um,
they're going to get unfocused.
They're going to start thinking about,
you know,
they're gonna start thinking about things that are,
are not good to think about because we want to,
yes,
we want a more,
we want to do the,
we want to remember.
But at the same time,
and I say this all the time,
we don't want to do well.
You don't want to dwell in the past.
You want to remember,
but don't dwell.
So I say,
get back to work.
Going back to what we talked about earlier,
find out what your next mission is going to be.
You have more of a reason to achieve your mission because you lost someone that
you lost.
Someone that can't kick,
that can no longer carry on with their mission.
So for them,
carry on with your mission.
Go forward.
Don't dwell in the past.
Anybody that you asked that you cared about,
what would they want you to do?
Would they want you to sit around and sulk and look at the ground?
No,
they'd want you to get your gear,
get your mindset straight and get back after it.
So that's what I recommend.
I think that's,
that's exactly right.
And I think getting a work,
uh,
the reason that's important is if people,
if
that person died,
you know,
in,
for the guys that we lost,
I get,
if we just,
if we just gave up and walked away,
that means they died in vain for nothing.
And,
and we're not gonna do that.
We're going to,
we're going to double a triple,
quadruple down on that mission to make sure that we win,
that their sacrifices weren't,
weren't advantage.
I think that's helping the team understand,
uh,
what you're accomplishing and why they're doing what they're doing is,
is incredibly important.
And we wrote about that and extreme ownership and talk about it all the time.
That,
that understanding why briefing the team and helping them understand why it is
critical,
but yeah,
focused on accomplishing that mission is,
uh,
is what you gotta do.
I think the other thing too is you'll do everything you can to take care of
that,
that person and their family take care of their family and help them out.
And you know,
that's an obligation that never goes away.
Now you're always going to have a,
and that's extremely important and something that's,
uh,
that's helped me through those difficult losses is by serving others and
looking,
trying to look out for others.
Uh,
and I got to do that even more than I do.
Um,
you know,
another thing that can help out in those dark times is a little bit of Jujitsu
to be quite frank with you.
Next question's about Jujitsu.
Again,
my BJJ coach knows it all.
The problem is he's a know it all condescending,
insulting,
derogatory comments to students while class is in session.
Option A,
stay option B,
go to a school down the road with less experienced but much more mature minded
teacher.
What would jack would do?
What would life do?
What would echo do?
I would probably move.
Okay,
fair enough.
It's straightforward to depends how,
maybe not that straight fans,
how much less experienced though.
Yeah.
Okay.
But,
but purple belt,
Brown belt it move.
If I'm just beginning white belt,
whatever.
Yeah.
Oof.
Okay.
Leif Babin yeah.
Look it as,
as a white belt myself that I learned from,
there's amazing purple belts in Brown belts out there.
You know,
I've learned a ton from you after you always show up,
show me stuff.
And,
and you,
you have a great knack for teaching,
which is getting,
you know,
people,
some people just don't have that as much.
And I think,
uh,
um,
yeah,
I think that's,
if you're at the white belt level,
that's,
that's great.
So,
uh,
I think that's a
Jocko apparently disagrees.
I know that goes a very good teacher.
That is a echos.
You can see as you can see him swell up a little bit,
gets that,
loves it.
A Lafe said it a impartial.
Listen,
that's cause I've been,
you have taught me things.
I imagine you have a dot.
Jocko.
Think sit in that way.
And he,
even if he would,
yeah,
you should,
you should go over that.
Maybe we should do that right now.
Kuma take down.
But look,
I,
yeah,
I think you can learn from a lot of different people and wheeled down one thing.
You just can't make sure that you can't make it.
You make sure it's ego getting in the way
and when someone's really coaching and saying,
Hey,
you need to do this,
you need to get better.
And you just don't like the manner in what's there.
They're doing it public or whatever.
You might need to put your ego in check and just say,
okay,
I don't know everything.
Of course you don't,
let's learn.
Uh,
if it's over the top,
then yeah,
absolutely.
You should go where you can learn,
uh,
best [inaudible] and the quality of the people around you that you're rolling
with this we talked about earlier.
I mean,
that's,
that to me is everything.
Uh,
and,
and that's what I love about Jujitsu is just the,
you know,
such a diverse group of people.
When you get a great gym that you're trying to edit and just folks who are
working together and learning together and uh,
you know,
they get the best of you and then they're,
they're willing to show you about how they did that or some things you should
think about it.
Keep it a secret.
But my opinion on that as well,
just to,
yeah,
I agree with you guys,
but at the same time I'll say this,
one of the things you got to learn to do in life is you got to learn that you're
not going to get along with everyone.
And not everyone's personality is going to Mesh with yours.
That doesn't mean you throw away the baby with the bath water.
You see what I'm saying?
So there might be a guy that he's not a good teacher.
He treats people like crap,
but he's got really good information and you're learning a lot and you,
so we're going to take as much knowledge as I can from that person.
I'm not just going to walk away because I don't like his attitude.
You know what?
You're going to have people that you work for that have bad attitudes,
and you're gonna have people that work for you that have bad attitudes.
You're going to have to learn to deal with it.
You're gonna have to learn how to get as much out of them as you can out of
everybody as a leader.
Everybody that you got there,
there's people that are going to be good at this,
but they're good at that.
Okay,
well let's,
let's capitalize on what they're good at.
So this guy,
very knowledgeable,
kind of a jerk.
Let's capitalize on the fact that he's very knowledgeable.
Put your ego in check and show up there.
Take the knowledge from him,
and then years to come.
You pay him back.
Pay Him a visit.
Yeah,
I've,
ah,
I dig it.
Sure.
And that's me.
But overall there's two.
But
if yes,
if you're getting the knowledge,
you're,
you emphasizing your life cruising.
No,
no.
And I emphasize in my life getting after it.
So for this,
therefore you're at that,
you're like,
oh,
this guy doesn't cruise hard enough.
Right.
We might be coming.
I want to get after it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I dig it in.
But I think at the end of the day,
if,
how you said the guy,
yeah,
he's not saying cool stuff,
are you saying stuff that's not cool or whatever,
but you're still getting the information then okay.
You know,
and also just like,
um,
we,
Jordan Peterson and like it pays off in life to have thick skin.
Like you're going to be successful.
Like that's one of the ingredients were for success.
Like dig it.
So if you're giving the information for sure.
But a lot of times with the node all situation,
which is the words he used,
um,
I've been in that situation like a few times where it's like,
I see what you're doing there.
And being the guy who's kind of had some experiences,
I'm thinking like,
I don't know the circumstances that you're talking about that's not going to
work.
And I know that just from experience or whatever,
but this guy a know it all and no,
no,
I know you don't know kind of attitude or whatever.
And if that's the way the whole teaching experiences and learning,
quote unquote learning experiences,
I think,
I think more benefits would be gathered elsewhere.
Yeah.
It's interesting when late from you're talking about,
yeah,
you use your kid as a task for yourself to calm down and get more mature and
detach and all that.
That's good advice.
Can elastically doing that all the time.
Like when I,
when I meet someone that that is rubs me the wrong way.
I always look at that like,
okay,
cool.
I'm going to form a relationship with this person,
become their best friend and and see if I can get there.
This a big,
it happened so that's maybe what I do with that.
She just a trickle wall by wall by the way.
I'm taking all of his knowledge from him so I can formulate it into goodness.
Again,
if you getting the knowledge good men good,
but as a white belt it's like,
come on bro,
you to eat.
You want to get the best teaching learning overall Jujitsu experience possible.
That's where,
you know,
like as a new beginner,
white belt or whatever,
I'm going to come in and then just get insulted by a know it all or whatever.
Like I don't know,
even know if I like Jujitsu now kind of things are good and you run that role.
It's not good for business,
that's for sure.
So of course,
hey,
you're Jocko.
I get it man.
Life gets it.
But we're not all Jocko.
When someone says like,
or is a know it all and I'm supposed to trust this person to teach me.
Do you get to,
because you know for all the great reasons we take Jiu Jitsu and I'm trusting
this person and they're going to be like how this guy explained.
I don't know man.
I don't know.
Repeat question mark.
There you go.
Deep down the street and train.
That's fine.
I would rather get 99% of the knowledge from a good purple belt than 5% of the
knowledge of a know it all guy.
Okay.
There's,
there's,
there's clean argument for that.
Next question.
This is from a VJ normal Kumar.
He's been,
he's been on in the game for a long time.
Yeah,
I've got a lot of,
a lot of lists.
Do you know,
we've got a lot of listeners in India.
No,
that,
yeah.
Actually I taught VJ from time to time online check.
So he says you must have had good days and awful ones in the field.
How did you manage to stay focused despite the ups and downs?
How did you win over the darkness?
Also?
What was your workout like when you guys were engaged in the field and probably
tired?
Two questions there.
I think how you manage the ups and downs is,
is uh,
you got to stay focused
on what the goal is.
You know,
and I think we talk about that,
how the recognition,
you know,
when we came back from that deployment and you put that slide together about the
bowel of that kind of capture on this map,
you know,
the,
uh,
the areas that we'd taken back.
And even though I had planned and lead those operations,
um,
eat,
you know,
so many of those operations.
I've been intimately involved in the planning and leading those ops and in
writing,
you know,
post operational summaries and all the reports that we,
we had and was involved in some of the battalion and brigade level meetings.
Uh,
you know,
for that,
that whole strategic plan.
Uh,
I didn't really have a fully grass,
just,
I didn't put it all together and that way.
And when you,
when I saw that slide that you put together that showed,
you know,
the,
the red
enemy held areas of Ramadi and all of a sudden blue circles going in the u s
basis,
uh,
that were put in,
that we were often the lead element on the ground for,
um,
it put it all together for me in a way that,
that I had not seen before and that I recognize I had to do better job with my
guys of doing that too.
And I think that's something that for every leader,
that's where that detachment comes in to to be able to think,
okay,
help me understand what this is all about through the dark times,
through the rough times,
so I can focus on what the strategic goal is.
Uh,
and uh,
and so I can help the team understand that as well.
And I think,
uh,
that's,
that's something that,
you know,
if you step back from the details,
kind of think about it so that you can understand it and then impart that team
that to your team so they get an understanding.
It's,
it enables them to slog through a,
when it's,
when it's really difficult and it's a,
it's dangerous or,
or they've got some real challenges ahead,
but they can stay focused on that,
that uh,
that go,
you also got to remember what it feels like to do the right thing for me.
Like I know what it feels like to not do the right thing and I don't like that
feeling later.
Right.
It feels good right now to not do the right thing because you're like,
oh,
cool bag of Cheetos and I'm going to get something right.
You know what,
that feels good right there.
We know what it feels like later.
You know,
you went off the path and that's not good.
So I just always think,
okay,
well I'm gonna,
I'm gonna suck it up now.
Take the,
take the problem now take the hard path now because I know later it's gonna pay
off.
I'm gonna feel better in the long run.
Pay Now,
pay later,
pay now or pay later.
That stuck with me when he said it was good.
Yeah.
I like it when you pay now and pay later.
Sometimes she do that take sometimes pay the man now and then pay them in late
and then hey asked about workouts too while we're in the field.
And this is a good one cause you know like firefighters,
right?
Firefighters are on duty for 24 hours.
So that means they're going to get a workout in at some,
sometimes they do more than that.
But the new 24 hours on,
on,
on duty,
where there at the station waiting for a call.
Are you going to do,
let's say one of the workouts from this sprinkles freedom field manual,
are you going to do the three sets of 20 rep squats with 20 minute rest in
between?
I think they call those widow maker.
Are you going to do that?
If you,
if,
if within like 15 minutes you might be called on to carry a kid down a ladder,
don't do that workout then cause you won't be ready.
And that's kind of the attitude in Ramadi.
It was like,
yeah we,
we,
we trained hard certainly.
And it,
you know,
we talked about that on,
on a podcast 65 that the things they carried and,
and uh,
how we had to be,
we had to train hard,
but you had to always hold a little back because you never knew when you're
going to get to call.
And,
and you certainly,
after a big blow up squat workout like that,
I mean,
you weren't going to be able to run to the streets and run upstairs and drag
your 215 pound buddy was 60 pounds of gear on,
you know,
for 50 yards across the open street while shooting with the other hand.
So,
I mean those are the kinds of things where you gotta be ready for that.
And you could,
you had to leave a little reserve in the tank.
Um,
just in case,
uh,
because we got often we're like,
oh,
we don't have an option.
Right.
Oh,
we do have an opt in and get ready.
right on.
Yeah.
So leave a little in the tank.
That's a good way of putting it.
Okay.
Here's a good one.
Next question.
This is for both of you.
Did either of you ever get into serious trouble as a team before joining the
military or will you always exceptionally disciplined from a young age?
Uh,
the Rafe Babbitt exceptionally disciplined from you.
The reason I'm laughing,
if my,
if my parents,
uh,
or,
or listening to this and they're probably laughing hysterically right now.
So as,
as our mind,
this is,
yeah,
I got an all kinds of trouble,
all kinds of trouble all the time.
I was a total wild man.
I,
I'm,
can you shoot your brother with an Arrow in the leg or something?
I know he stabbed himself.
Oh,
okay.
He stabs that.
We used to shoot each other with BB guns still in the list all the time.
That was,
and we threw spears and each other,
uh,
you know,
in high school I drove around with an old beat up pickup truck and I heard it
from my,
my uncle who had inherited from my grandfather and smash road signs and just
knucklehead stuff.
And,
uh,
yeah,
I was a complete idiot.
And,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
in the military help score me way certainly.
And it was,
uh,
I'm lucky that I didn't do something that caused me to have lifelong injury or
death or damage.
And,
you know what I think or do something that you get a bunch of trouble for it for
sure that would have changed your jack to prevented me from going to the naval
cam prevented me from going in the military and,
and,
and would've,
that would've redrafted my,
my whole life.
So I think,
uh,
you know,
if you're in that stage and you're,
you're a wild teen,
you need to think clearly about the longterm consequences,
uh,
because,
you definitely can pay the man now and pay later.
And that situation,
for sure.
One of the things that we do is as young boys,
I'm speaking from a boy perspective because I'm not a girl.
And when I was growing up and with the way I look back on it now,
a lot of the stuff that we did,
dumb stuff that we did as teenagers was,
uh,
we were testing each other and we were trying to prove ourselves that I'm tough
watching me do this.
Like,
um,
it's almost,
it's almost like if you go instinctually as a tribe member,
you're proving that you're willing to sacrifice,
you're willing to take risk and sacrifice.
That's what you're proving to your peers.
Like I'm gonna like what you just said,
pickup truck.
I'm going to drive down the road and I'm going to,
I'm going to run over this sign.
Well,
okay,
it's funny,
but you're also proving to your friends that you don't really care.
I can take risk and you'll do things for the tribe.
That's kind of what you're proving.
So I think,
again,
I don't want to sound like a going back to the same broken record,
but if you want to get your kid,
or if you're a kid and you want to prove yourself,
guess what you can do?
You can go take Jujitsu.
You can learn how to fight for real.
You can learn how to defend yourself.
You can learn how to take care of your tribe,
take care of yourself,
take care of your family.
You can do,
you can learn how to beat up other people,
which is an important thing.
I wish I would've known it.
When you know what you did to you,
you have less of a chance of getting into a fight because the way you act is
different.
You don't act like a jackass cause you realize that you
might get stabbed and so you act respectful to people and people can tell that
and you're respectful back to you.
So yeah,
it's just another thing I think helps out a lot with kids cause I think boys are
always trying to prove themselves to each other and to themselves that you're
tough and that you're brave.
I'm trying to prove that.
You know how many,
let's just,
let's just survey.
How many times did you jump off the roof of buildings?
A lot.
Yeah.
It's like,
why are you doing that?
We actually used to go when I was,
we'd go a fishing [inaudible]
the oil rigs off the coast go deep sea fishing and you might run 40 or 50 miles
off and um,
w you're not supposed to get on the rigs.
There's all these signs and stuff,
but we totally get up on the rig and just jump off at 60 feet off the top of the
rig,
which was awesome.
It hurts a little bit,
but I said it was good times,
but we do things to prove that we're tough.
I did a lot of dumb things when I was a kid and most of them were to prove to
myself and to my friends that I was tough and then I was committed and that I
would take risks,
which are all that was crazier than that,
which are all positive qualities,
right?
That you want.
Like we were in the teams.
What kind of guy?
What kind of teammate do you want?
You want a guy that's aggressive,
you want a guide that will take risks if he needs to.
You want a guy that's committed,
that's what you want.
So in these little weird tribes that we have as teenagers,
that's when we have,
and what are you going to do to prove,
well,
let's go get a fight with somebody.
Let's go beat someone up.
You know,
there's all those dumb things that you do.
So be smart,
be smart.
Neither one of us,
uh,
were model children to say to say the least.
All right.
Lafe next one.
[inaudible] first off,
thanks for picking up the spear.
I'm interested to hear more about the mujahideen in Ramadi.
How did they stack up against US forces?
Was it like an NFL team playing against the high school team or did they have
tactics,
training and discipline equal to our own?
Well,
first of all,
I appreciate the thanks,
but it was an honor for me to carry the spear and as,
as we said,
we'd go back there in a heartbeat.
Certainly this is a great question.
It's,
it's an as a great question.
I think it really gets to the heart of what we talk about all the time is the
greatest quality in a leader in that as humility.
Um,
and when you look at the Mujahideen,
uh,
or the Mooc as we call them,
right?
The enemy fighters who control Ramadi.
There were several thousand of them by,
by a u s intelligence reports,
uh,
estimates one who controlled two thirds of the geographic area,
the city when we first arrived in the spring of 2006 with tasking at bruiser
when Jack and I were there.
And,
uh,
you know,
we were showing up our,
our,
our seals or some of the best shooters in the world.
There's some of the best combat troops in the world.
We have a highly screened group of guys who've been through all that,
the seal training pipeline.
That's a year and a half long,
probably at a minimum.
And then we've worked together for almost a year as a,
as a seal platoon.
We've got guys with extraordinary physical fitness.
Uh,
we'd go to these awesome shooting schools.
We trained together,
we have,
we have the best budget and gear,
you know,
that,
that uh,
all the giant special operations,
uh,
in a budget can buy a,
that's turning in equipment.
And,
uh,
so when we get there,
we're,
we're
ready to go and pound for pound.
If you take,
you know,
a CEO operator and from Charlotte batoon versus one of the Moose fighters that
were going up against that seal operator can do hundreds of pushups.
He can do hundreds of bullets.
NFL versus grade school.
Exactly.
And that the,
you know,
the,
the MOOC fighter,
he has virtually no training.
He could probably can't do 10 pushups.
He's,
uh,
he has none of the gear and awesome gear that we have.
And um,
and it's so it's pound for pound.
It's not even comparable.
And yet to think about this from,
from the reality perspective,
right in,
in my book,
in charter between,
we had 16 seals and five of those guys were brand new,
straight out of training,
never been,
never been in combat before,
never deployed to Iraq,
five of us.
And we're going up against the enemy that has had three years at that time,
three straight years of nonstop real world combat experience.
And so the,
the experience level is not even comparable when we're going up against these
guys.
They know the city,
they,
I mean,
and they're able to use our weaknesses against us.
Whereas we got to carry all the heavy weight and the body armor and helmets and,
and,
and we're not a climatized to 115 or 120 degree high,
uh,
during the,
during the day and the heat of the summertime.
They are,
and they lived there and they don't have to carry water on them and they don't
have to carry body armor and helmets.
And they,
they,
uh,
they can just throw a backpack with seven RPG rockets in a,
in a,
in a rocket tube and rolled out with their flip flops and knock off Adidas
tracksuit,
which is what they generally war.
And,
uh,
and you know,
or their belt fed,
no Russian machine guns.
And they use,
they weren't near as good as the ones we had,
but they were,
they were deadly and they could use them and they could shoot.
And,
and so you can never,
ever,
ever take those guys for granted.
And I think that's the,
if they would always be looking to probe weaknesses and they weren't there to
fight us head to head,
they would try to take advantage of our weaknesses.
They were very good at analyzing a situation,
looking at a weakness and taking advantage of that weakness or probing for him.
Uh,
and if you ever took them for granted,
I mean they were,
they were going to there,
you were setting yourself,
they might hit you hard anyway and you might get lose guys,
uh,
even if he were prepared.
But if you weren't prepared and he started taking for the him for granted,
you sort of get complacent and a,
and not respecting them as an enemy,
uh,
then then you are going to fail.
And they kind of mean,
for lack of a better word,
they cheat too.
That's the thing,
right?
Looks you guys have rules of engagement for sure.
This stuff and they just straight up.
And what's I would say even more important than that is they don't have value
for human life.
Value their own lives.
They're,
they're literally suicide bombers.
And so that,
you know,
they could lose five.
They want to die,
they want it,
they want to achieve martyrdom in many cases.
And so,
you know,
them dying is,
is not a huge impact.
And then obviously for,
for Americans and American soldiers in our friends,
it's,
it's APIC and,
and crushing loss of life every single time.
And so that is the,
the biggest differences that we have to,
it's like being in,
it's like,
you know,
he says it,
this is what he says.
He says it's his NFL versus the high school team,
right?
Well,
the,
if the NFL should destroy that team,
right?
Completely destroy it.
But if the high school team scores a single point,
the kick a field goal,
they get lucky and kick a field goal,
that's it.
That's a win.
And it has,
that's crutch,
that's crushing.
And that's kind of what it's like.
They're not going to win.
They're not going to win the game.
But even when they put a score on the board,
man,
it,
it's crushing.
And one thing that I think about it too,
that what was unique about that tasking,
a bruiser deployment to Ramadi and 2006 was I deployed three times to Iraq.
A headquarter Jocko made multiple deployments.
Our rack.
We've a lot of,
you know,
we had a handful of guys who've been there multiple times,
the guys who went later Afghanistan and,
and uh,
and,
and elsewhere around the world and saw significant combat operations.
But what was unique about that was we were,
we were going on foot did you want to drive?
Cause you gonna get blown up with these,
you know,
horrific ids are going to destroy your vehicles.
So we park our vehicles,
we had to carry everything on our backs and,
and,
and walk into deep,
deep in enemy territory in place where we knew that it was very unlikely that
that tanks could even get to us to help us out in some cases.
Um,
and if they did,
if they were going to try to come in and they might very well get blown up and
kill.
So what was interesting about that is,
you know,
we might have eight or 10 or you know,
seal.
Sometimes it may be he was 20 seals,
but,
but that's a fairly small group.
You know,
we had some Iraqi soldiers with us,
but we didn't count them when it came to,
uh,
they didn't count when it came to a,
hey,
who's going to actually be able to defend this position?
But I had to have the expectation that,
that we might very well have 50,
60 enemy fighters surrounding our position attack us and they could easily
overrun us.
And what was unique about that?
The point was we didn't have dedicated air support.
We didn't have a dedicated quick reaction force that was going to come out and,
and help us.
That only was supporting us.
Um,
unlike,
you know,
some other of combat operations that are,
that have happened elsewhere and it was a,
or on other departments that I was on and we were on our own.
We had a plan for that and you had to recognize that they could add,
they would absolutely bring it and they would try to kill you,
overrun your position to kill everybody,
capture someone.
And that was a real possibility that we had to be a,
we had to recognize,
could happen at any time and we had to be ready for it.
Well,
just to,
just to stay at the statement of fact,
on top of what you're saying,
the enemy did.
The enemy did overrun friendly positions multiple times while we're there and
killed dozens of people in some of those,
you know,
some of those heavily fortified ETPs would get completely overrun attack to
overrun vehicle born IED.
So it,
yeah,
it wasn't like this could happen.
This is actually happening while we were there.
Friendly positions got overrun by the enemy.
And so yeah,
it was not just,
it could happen,
but it is happening and it's a,
it's a,
it could happen to us tonight,
tomorrow night,
whenever they were good,
they use cover move.
I mean they laid down fire support each other.
They,
they,
they bind together plants.
They'd combined arms,
you know,
they'd come in with,
uh,
the,
the machine gun fire and then the RPG fire and the mortar fire.
And then all of a sudden there'd be a VB.
That's,
that's what they do.
And there were different levels within there as well.
I mean,
sometimes you get shot at and it was kind of a spray and pray someone dumping or
an AK and your direction.
And then other times you'd have multiple belt fed machine guns hitting you that
were,
you know,
coming through a little,
three or a three by four foot window from a hundred yards away.
Uh,
and they're coming inches over your head and you're looking at each other like,
man,
these guys know what they're doing.
They,
they,
uh,
so you,
you could tell when,
you know,
the,
the guys who've been there for awhile maybe come from elsewhere.
Uh,
they brought it and you could never take them for granted.
And also,
luckily for us,
even though we might not had a dedicated QRF,
we had the best damn Q and f in the world,
which was absolutely the One,
one a.
And they were awesome and never failed to come in and save any acids,
have tue.
They brave those roads over and over and over and over again,
jumping in their tanks,
taking such tremendous risk are driving it home,
these down,
these horribly dangerous roads.
We didn't want to drive to come help us out and they do that all the time.
They were,
they were awesome.
We couldn't have done any of our operations without,
without them.
Next question,
and that's actually a good question.
It's,
it's how did the Naval Academy prepare you to lead?
And actually a lot,
a lot of listeners at the naval academy and a lot of listeners at west point,
um,
I hear from him and actually I got sent,
that's really the helmet I got sent.
Somebody sent me a hand painted navy football helmet.
It's pretty awesome with a warship on it.
Yeah,
I'll show it to you this afternoon.
It's awesome.
Thanks for sending me that by the way.
So like,
like I said,
a lot of listeners,
we've had Brian Stann on,
you know,
he talked about his experiences there and a lot of leadership he got from the
Naval Academy was actually from playing football.
When you listen to him,
he's playing football at the Naval Academy,
which was,
was a challenge for him,
but he learned a lot of leadership lessons there.
How did the Naval Academy prepare you to lead?
Well,
first of all,
I love my spirits of the naval academy.
And for me that was all about the,
the people that I serve with,
you know,
in the folks that I met and uh,
and the things that we went through together.
I've gotten a lot of trouble.
The Naval Academy,
uh,
I struggled my grades,
something we talked about previously.
Uh,
I got,
I had a big conduct record because I still did some of this knucklehead teenage
things and rebelled against authority.
But frankly,
uh,
you know,
look,
there's great people there.
You know,
there's great people on the staff.
I've got a very close friend,
there's a battalion officer now and it's awesome to have good people there that
are passing lessons on to,
you know,
to those young Midshipman as,
as a graduating and for every academy or ROTC unit know,
uh,
for that matter I saw,
you know,
cause you have such a wide swath of,
of officers from all different,
uh,
um,
you know,
from all different,
um,
uh,
Navy Marine Corps.
I mean every,
every kind of different branch of within those services as well.
And,
uh,
and also you have a,
an a midshipman leadership hierarchy,
right?
So you've got someone who,
because they made good grades are headed good.
Connor ever got,
got promoted into this kind of make believe position.
That right there.
A little bit of,
a little bit of anger about that one right there.
Just because they got good grades or they didn't have a good cognitive,
they really don't fit in conduct.
Record this,
they're going to charge me.
Listen there,
there were some resentful.
This is a new way.
If I just met a new life,
resentful,
I'm actually not at all resentful.
I,
uh,
I can tell you I had some,
I had some good friends who were in those positions and it was great for them,
you know,
good for them.
Um,
it's,
it's Kinda,
it's just,
it's funny looking back now cause it's completely meaningless right when you're,
do you have a regimental commander there?
Yeah.
There's that guy in charge of all the students.
There's,
there's,
you know,
there's a regiment,
brigade battalion.
I had ocs.
They have it too.
When I was at ocs I was the man.
I was cool.
I was with a regimen redcom so,
so no wonder is a little sense of this.
He's a little red car hot and they also called it the five bar because either
the only person with five bars on your little uniform.
Did they,
did they call you captain?
Big Time though?
They cut me off President Day.
I was the president of my class to write a good time at ocs.
So,
so now,
now we see the sensitivity there.
Listen,
I,
you know,
great.
We maybe you should've studied harder.
I need some kids now or I hear from a guy,
I get correspondence from people at the naval academy and like I can see that
they're in the game.
I can see that.
They're like,
oh,
this is going on and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you think you could've been,
you could've had that no question about it.
Now would it have mattered at the time?
I don't know.
You know,
failure as we say is often the best teacher.
Look,
I,
I made,
I made great grades in high school and did well on my sats and acds without,
with almost no study.
Uh,
I got super,
um,
uh,
I,
I just,
I didn't have the discipline that was in place.
Uh,
once I got to the Naval Academy,
that structure that it was,
it was difficult for me.
It was very hard for me as I went into assistant engineering program and,
and those sort of things.
So,
so I struggle with that.
So that could have helped me if somebody hit,
if I had to learn discipline equals freedom at a,
at a young age and recognize the power in that I'd be way,
way more ahead in life and we all for sure.
What about playing the game and playing the game as well,
right.
That I'm going to buck authority of like,
you know what,
actually it's going to be a lot worse for you if you just,
even from a personal perspective,
not only works for you but your for your squad or for your,
you know,
these folks that you care about.
If you just build a better relationship with the folks above you instead of
being the the,
you know,
hardheaded argumentative guy for sure it would be way better for him.
I don't know.
When I figured that out,
I mean it was definitely,
it was definitely in my enlisted time.
I started figuring out that I'm working for a guy and I can either make my life,
I can either tell him he socks and then my life is going to suck out or I can
figure out how to work with him.
And that's going to make my life better.
And by the way,
it's not just gonna make my life better.
It's gonna make us do a better job as a team.
So it's interesting when you pick up on that in life.
And obviously if I would have been going to the Naval Academy at 18 I was a
knucklehead,
you know,
I would have been in the same boat of like,
oh,
I'm going to stick it to the man.
Right?
I mean,
I'm still listening.
It's tenacious d at Age,
whatever.
And we're still sticking it to the man.
Well,
I'll tell you the people that I realized,
like my upperclassmen,
I really like,
and we have some that are still serving the seal teams and,
and a great guy as it helped influence me.
And,
and I expected when I showed up there,
I want it to be a seal.
Yeah.
I wanted to go to war.
That's what I wanted to do.
And I,
it was very hard for me to recognize that like not everybody wanted to do that.
It was exactly like me or was.
So it was a,
you know,
that some people were a little more academic and wonder to be on the
intelligence side or wanting to be,
you know,
they wanted to drive a ship or they wanted to be on a submarine or that,
those things that uh,
you know,
fly a plane.
I mean top gun had come basket,
but you know,
we had a whole bunch of people that want,
wanted to be,
you know,
pilots that had gone to school.
So it was,
it was interesting.
People were a lot different than I expected and,
and uh,
some folks didn't quite have the,
the war lack mentality that,
uh,
that I expected everyone might have,
um,
you know,
going,
going into that environment.
But there's no question that,
uh,
I,
if I had done a better job of,
you know,
you call it playing,
playing the games,
it just seeing that,
you know,
detaching and seeing like,
hey listen,
thinking strategically,
thinking strategically.
You want to see how if we were like,
don't want to say play the game.
Cause that sounds too to build,
I want to build relationships.
Dbs.
That is not,
I didn't recognize that it was not in my benefit or the benefit of the people
around me to,
to create antagonistic relationships and that,
so rather than deescalate those situations,
I rebelled against them and pushed against them.
And,
and it,
it,
it was a struggle for me and it took me a long time to figure that out.
That that being said though,
they're there,
you know,
there's,
the naval calves are different than anywhere else.
There was great leaders there who mentored people and train people and
represented,
you know,
folks well that we're both officers on the staff.
And I listen on the staff as well as a,
you know,
as Mitchem.
And so,
uh,
but I think what,
what was the lesson for me and looking back on it now that I recognize it's
great to identify who you don't want to be and if someone does something that's
looking out for themselves or throw those people under the bus or you know,
those,
those leaders that you start losing respect for,
it's great to actually identify that.
And that's a good lesson to learn to say,
okay,
good.
I want to make sure I don't be that that way.
But what,
what I have learned is that I can't be,
we talked to leaders about this all the time and I get people like,
what do you do?
You know,
when your boss is just using a good leader,
you're like,
guess what?
The seal teams is one of the most highly screened organizations in the world.
What's,
uh,
what's the percentage of senior leaders that I worked for that I had respect
for,
that I'd go and work for again,
that's maybe,
maybe 20%,
maybe 20% of the people I worked for during my time and get,
that's about average.
As you talk to people,
you know,
it's about average in the business world is better.
It's certainly the naval cab,
any of those places.
So if you're expecting that there's most of the world out there is not going to
be a good leader,
they're not going to get later.
And that doesn't matter.
That shouldn't affect your performance.
You should be able to do,
you know,
something that I learned from you,
which has probably been the most helpful thing that you ever taught me was that
I should try to have the same relationship with,
with every boss.
You know,
whether I had deep respect for an aberration for them or whether I despise them
and thought they were,
you know,
Egomaniac who you know,
are a coward,
who,
you know,
could mitigate risks.
So,
and that it's,
it's in my benefit and my team's benefit to build that relationship with,
with my team.
And that was,
that was a lesson that I had not learned in.
Um,
so yeah,
those negative,
those negative lesson learns.
We're,
we're,
we're good for me.
Um,
and also,
uh,
I would have had less negative a lessons learned how to figure this out earlier
check,
same.
And really we got time for like one more question,
but it's,
it's almost the same vein.
So I think it's a good question to ask.
It's as life.
At what points did you become enlightened to extreme ownership and how did you
respond to the philosophy?
Kind of same vein of what you were just talking about.
Exactly.
I mean I,
I clearly didn't have that fully at the Naval Academy,
but I started to understand through the kind of school of hard knocks and
falling on my face and get into much of trouble and realizing like,
hey,
it doesn't benefit me to rebel against authority or you know,
not do what I'm told or be seen as,
you know,
as someone who's,
doesn't respect the rules or whatever.
And,
and um,
I think I started to learn that a little more on the surface fleet cause I,
my goal,
I went out surfing,
it was crushing to me to not be selected out of the Naval Academy and to go into
the seal program.
So as I went out to the,
and served on a couple of different surface ships,
I recognize like the,
what is the pathway for me to,
to the seal teams,
but my lifelong dream,
that's all I want to do.
And it was be the best freaking surface warfare officer.
Now you got to,
just so everyone knows now you've got to earn a recommendation to go and do
this.
So if you're not the best fleet officer you could possibly be,
someone's going to go,
why would you,
why would you send you the seal teams and you,
you're not even doing a good job here.
No.
So you've got to earn a reputation.
You also have to,
and a recommendation for sure you.
So you have to build that trust with your bosses and you have to get qualified.
So they've got to trust you and you have to achieve that qualification.
You're not even eligible until you hit your warfare qualification.
When you reported on board a ship,
you have to do certain qualifications that say,
okay,
yes,
you are now a surface warfare officer,
qualified surface warfare officer.
There's a bunch of boxes.
You've got to check those boxes,
or you got to learn all kinds of information about all the hundreds of different
systems.
And until you get that,
you're not even going to get,
you're not getting a recommendation that you're not even eligible.
You're not even eligible.
So you had to,
you had to get,
so I do embrace it and that helped me.
And I still had frictions certainly.
And,
and,
but I started recognizing like what works and what doesn't and,
but it wasn't really until tasking at bruiser.
That's where you really quantify that for me.
And,
and you know,
as,
as we were going through,
I was in my second button and so I'd already been through a previous platoon
and,
um,
and I,
I didn't even realize like as in that second,
the second platoon is,
we were working at tasking at bruiser,
which Arneb tune.
I was like,
man,
we're good.
We're,
we're performing well.
And when we started having,
you know,
a few months into the workup cycle,
we'd have,
you know,
training instructors,
be like,
you guys are the best tasking that we've ever seen come through here.
And it was interesting to me cause I was like,
well,
I don't really,
I mean we have some amazing guys in this task in it,
but I had amazing guys in my last task.
It too,
but we had very talented,
so it's not really the talent factor that broke us out.
You know?
And and I didn't even realize he certainly wasn't that we didn't make mistakes
cause we made all kinds of mistakes and tasking at bruiser and you know,
disastrous training operations where we had to come back and revamp our training
process and,
and make sure that we dialed in standard operating procedures.
Just what trainees exactly and right,
exactly.
That's the difference really.
Yeah.
And that was it.
It was,
it was this idea that we now call extreme ownership,
which is we're going to take ownership of this and instead of being like,
hey,
we're going to push back and gets people that are telling us we need to be
better or we're going to eat,
maybe even deny that we're as bad as we are,
we're going to take a brutally honest assessment of ourselves.
And that was one thing that really stands out to me as I think about it.
Do you remember our,
our debriefs that the training instructors,
they're usually have,
it's super lengthy and critical debriefs.
We would debrief ourselves after a run because they let the,
they let the tunes and the task is to go first.
And so often it was the only time I ever saw it to all my,
you know,
my nine years in the seal teams that,
uh,
that,
that most of the time we would get done debriefing ourselves.
And,
and the training instructors did not have it.
They had either nothing to say or maybe just a couple of sentences.
And that was it.
Yeah.
Cause we'd rip ourselves to shreds cause we,
we,
we were,
that was such a brutally honest assessment of,
and sometimes they'd be like,
Hey,
I actually thought you guys did pretty good.
Showed up.
We're,
yeah,
we're working.
And that's actually you told,
you told them,
right?
They say the worst thing,
you don't ever tell my guys that,
uh,
that they're,
they're doing,
they're amazing.
That's the best one they ever seen because that,
that,
that allows us to not get better,
to not grow,
to get complacent.
So we always did that.
And I think that's,
I s I was starting to,
I recognized just how powerful that was to our performance.
So again,
we were never flawless.
We always made,
we made mistakes,
but we learn from those mistakes.
We got better,
we grew all the time and we were able to run circles around everybody else as a
result and deliver some exceptional performance on the battlefields with that
attitude.
And that's,
you know,
that that mindset and attitude is,
is the game changer.
That's why we called the book extreme ownership.
Uh,
and it's what we impart to people as,
as we see in the business world.
And if there's at the end of the day just what works and there's what doesn't
work,
but that Ti tasking a bruiser and working with you and recognizing what that is
and how powerful that is,
uh,
that's,
that's made all the difference.
It's crazy to see,
and I'd see this all the time that,
well,
you just think about what you're saying when the,
when the training contrary for instance,
tells you,
Hey,
it took you guys a long time to get a headcount,
meaning you're on the target.
And you want to leave the target before you leave the target.
You've got to know that you've got all your people,
so you want to get a headcount.
So the training contrary says,
Hey,
it took you guys a long time to get a headcount.
Now you can do one of two things here.
You can say,
okay,
that's because criticism.
How could we get faster headcount?
Hey guys,
anyone ever done this a different way?
Yeah,
Hey,
I've used this process in the past.
It works really good.
Okay,
let's try that.
Oh,
that worked better.
And we do this one little thing.
It can be even a little bit faster.
Okay,
let's rehearse it.
Let's actually try and rehearse it.
Okay,
boom.
Now we're getting really good.
So,
so we take that and all of a sudden the next time we go out,
we do a little bit better and then we've modified a little bit more and all of a
sudden we can get a headcount in 15 seconds instead of four minutes.
Which is a huge difference when you're trying to leave a target.
So that's one attitude to have.
That's like,
we're going to take ownership of the problems.
But I would see this all the time,
which is,
hey guys,
your head count was a little slow and guys get up.
It wasn't that bad,
wasn't that bad.
And when we,
it took us four minutes,
four minutes is not that big of a deal
like,
or,
or like the,
that guy saying that right now.
But I'd like to see him get a head count faster than that.
And when we did it as fast as we could do it,
everyone counted as fast as we could.
And we made it through the first time that took us three minutes and they're
going to say,
that's not good enough.
A,
don't worry about that.
And so,
so you're going to stay on that pattern and you never get better and you're
never going to get better.
And it's cause you're not looking at your,
you're not accepting criticism from the outside.
And it's like when we see that with leaders now,
I started laughing,
Dave,
Dave and I were just working with it with,
with a team and,
and uh,
we had that.
It comes up all the time.
And it's funny when you see people pushing back against them,
some real constructive criticism,
and my question is always like,
oh,
okay.
I said,
it's just,
you know that battle of Egos there.
I look at that and say,
okay,
what you're telling it,
just,
just let me understand.
You're telling me that you,
you are at absolute optimal performance and you can never improve in any way
then that does that,
does that,
is that what you're saying?
And obviously then they ran it as like,
of course not there.
So,
so that kind of opens the door of,
yeah,
you can improve and you should improve.
And if you're not,
what you taught me is not only should you improve,
I think the big lesson that I learned from you and that we now teach here with
echelon front is,
is that if not only should you improve,
but if you're not trying to do better,
if you're not doing everything you can to have the most efficient and effective
headcount that you can and improve in every aspect of your game,
all the time,
that you're actually failing you as a leader and you're failing your team.
And I think that's a very fundamental difference of looking at it,
that it's,
it's not just know I should be doing that,
but no,
if I'm not doing that,
I'm a failure as a leader and I'm failing my team.
Yeah.
And all of this is weird,
you know,
talking about this headcount thing,
it's,
it's a great example.
I'm surprised I haven't talked about it very much because it's a,
it's a really big deal like for,
and when you leave at target,
you can't leave until you know that you have all your guys,
so you've got to get a head count.
There's multiple different ways to get a head count and the easiest ways you use
decentralized command in every little team leader counts there,
three or four guys and they go,
Yep,
one's up to is up threes up and they report in up one level and by the time I
would need a head count I'd look at life and,
and the Delta platoon commander and I'd be like,
Hey,
are we up?
And it would take them 10 seconds and like we're up the,
the way,
the worst way to do it,
which I would also see would be,
you would literally
from,
from the lowest guy,
there's 36 guys in the troop and someone would say,
hey head count.
And the back guy would go 36 35 and they,
you'd have assigned numbers 35343330230 was 31 oh over here.
Wait,
you're 31 no I'm 32 W did you count?
And so you need,
it takes three minutes,
four minutes.
And,
and yet it's like,
well that that's a very sensible way on paper to do it.
Cause you know you're going to have all your people but in reality doesn't work.
And that's that one.
And so this is that one little thing,
right?
This one little thing,
one little improvement you can make,
but,
but that's not the only improvement you can make.
You can improve every little thing that you do and every little thing that you
do as a team,
everything that you do as an individual human being,
you can make it just a little bit better.
And the minute that year you're,
you're seeing back new year your phone,
you know what,
I'm not going to make this change anymore.
Um,
I'm,
I've reached my pinnacle of performance in this category.
The minute that you're do that,
it's not just one category that you're slacking off on.
It's all of them.
And I was telling you guys the other day,
I'm like,
you know when you see me post a picture in the morning that is saying we've got,
I'm getting up,
but I'm mocking it before 30 if it does,
it says the four 35 that means I got up at four 30 and I got out of bed and I
went in and,
and,
and I took a picture of my watch and I post it when I'm posting it at four oh
eight that means I woke up and I was like,
I got to get busy is I,
it's not all,
it's not alarm clock.
I'm gotta get,
I gotta go do,
I've got to go make these things happen.
I gotta look and see where I can improve my method for getting a headcount.
How can I make it that much faster?
That one little thing.
And when you look at your array of what's your going on in your business and
it's also in your life,
do,
what can you do a little bit better?
You attack those problems.
You accept the criticism when it comes at you,
which is so hard for everyone to do,
myself included.
You accept the Chris,
he listened to it,
and then you modify and you make these little iterative changes and at the end,
instead of being a decent task unit or instead of being a decent person or
instead of running a decent team,
you can be the best.
And that's only happens if you take ownership of what's going on in your world
with that
Echo Charles.
Yes.
Speaking of taking ownership,
trying to get better.
Yes.
Maybe you could help us out with that a little bit.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that's possible.
That's interesting though.
Like where when you put it into perspective,
right?
The extreme ownership,
because you know how you say the biggest or one of the,
the biggest,
best qualities of a leader is humility.
Humility.
Yeah.
You see the tie in right now,
right?
More so.
Yes.
Because you figure,
okay,
so you said a little bit of a stripe stripe on the,
on the leadership white belts.
There you go.
So you get a team,
a team of people,
all different,
you know,
personalities,
whatever.
Eagles,
different varying levels,
right?
So for little,
there's going to be all these little problems.
No one's perfect,
no one's optimal,
right?
That's kind of the goal.
Even if it's unattainable perfection,
right?
That's the kind of the gold optimal.
Then you have a team with however many mistakes they make and then as they
train,
perform all this stuff,
all the little mistakes get pointed out.
And it's almost like this self,
uh,
self correcting organism.
We hope it is.
That's why,
yes,
you hope it is.
So like if you compare it to like a machine learning situation,
it does that cause it doesn't have ego,
it doesn't take things personal.
It's kind of like,
let me just solve all the little problems.
And then that's why they can grow and exponential rates.
Right.
The thing that's awesome about that though is that you get w w attic,
what you're talking about is building the culture,
right?
So you get,
if the leaders doing that and you get to team doing it once,
once people recognize like,
hey look how much better we are.
Head counts.
Even if our existed that then you start getting junior leadership who knew,
you know,
frontline troops,
new guys who,
you know,
they come up with an idea,
hey,
here's a way we can do this a little better.
Solving problems you don't even see.
Yeah.
It's a so saying that the other day,
you know,
I was,
I was at in a training situation the other day and I saw things go bad for this
group.
It was a military group and,
and things are going bad.
They weren't,
they all dropped the ball.
They all kind of drop the ball.
But there's slack there,
there were slack.
True.
And I was thinking to myself,
I wouldn't see,
uh,
a young but new guy,
machine gunner not get in a good position.
I would never see that with my eyes because the guy that was immediately senior
to him would,
would straighten them out.
There would be no slack right there.
There'd be no soccer.
Like he gets straight out.
So by the time I show up and I look around,
everyone's doing amazingly well.
Everything's the way it should be.
It's not quite optimal,
but it's damn close.
And why is that?
It's because what you just said life.
If it's because every leader,
every individual leader and every person is,
is adjusting and making things,
making adjustments that I'm not even seeing.
And why are they doing that?
Number one,
because they're all humble enough to look that they need to change things.
And number two,
everyone in the group has their ego in check.
So when someone says,
Hey,
shift,
you're fueled the fire a little bit to the West,
the guy doesn't say why.
Yeah,
no,
he goes,
I wonder why.
Oh I see.
Cause he's got another guy over there that's covering that feel.
If I got it,
got it.
Boss.
You know that's,
that's what,
that's it.
Now we have like,
like a machine that just improving all the time.
Yeah.
Which is what we're going for.
And if you lack humility in any,
in any one of those levels,
you're,
you're going to slow down that machine.
It's progress,
that process fully.
Duh.
Yeah.
So it's weird when you look at it from the big picture,
you know,
and you see like,
just like how you're saying when you kind of mentally compared your current team
with teams in the past like Oh,
there was talented guys on the other side,
on the other teams that I was on too.
But you kind of understand and recognize that one factor is that everyone's kind
of humbling is always constantly like,
what can I do better right here with my,
you know,
situation in my own little world here.
But everyone's
doing that.
So it's like this,
if you,
if you kind of collectively consider this group,
they're just humble,
boom,
self,
self entertaining,
one step forward.
Just,
just once that further,
just so everyone can think about how to implement this in your world,
the way you implement it isn't by saying,
guys,
the headcount will slow.
You need to fix it.
It's not by saying,
hey,
the approach to the target was too loud.
You need to be quiet.
That's not how you fix the problem.
You say,
hey guys,
our headcount is taking too long.
I need to come up with a better way to do it.
I need to,
I need,
I need to figure this out.
Or Hey guys,
we were too noisy going to the target.
I need to make sure that you have the gear that you need to,
and I need to make sure we all understand how important it is to be quiet going
to the target.
I think I was too loud,
right?
I think I was too loud.
Now everyone says Pam giagles like he's blaming himself for being too loud,
but I'm the one that was over the back there.
My drop my canteen.
It made a bunch of noise in the rocks.
That was my fault.
I'm going to tighten myself up.
Yeah,
as opposed to blaming everyone,
and we talk about this all the time.
The minute you're blaming everyone,
everyone's just,
you know,
they're looking for excuse,
they're blaming you.
You don't understand how hard it is to carry that canteen quietly.
And I was thirsty cause I've been carrying them machine gun and I needed to get
water right there.
I was going to get dehydrated.
They're just making excuses and the machine can't self correct and machine kid
self can't do it just stays in the one inefficient ineffective mode.
Speaking of machines,
machines need oil.
Hmm.
Not Necessarily Krill oil,
but we need krill oil.
B Plus a fee.
No,
already jumping to Jacqueline's supplements.
Good News.
I just took my Jocko Krill oil.
This small room gets so let me to always everyday.
Don't forget,
can't slack on that.
Thanks for bringing me some Krill oil in New York too by the way.
Yeah,
that you still owe me a bottle for them.
no problem.
I know a guy,
his name is Jocko and the Krill oil is called Jocko,
Super Krill and joint warfare by the way,
which is another joint supplement,
you know,
maintain the physical capabilities of your body.
Um,
I said don't forget to take it and don't run out by the way.
I ran out before.
But if you are running out,
there is a subscription option by real robust by request.
Yeah.
You get it.
Let every month you can get it every month,
every two weeks.
This,
well this was cool though because the indicator was when people order Krill
during warfare,
guess what they do?
They order more.
Yeah.
And then they order more so than the requests were.
Can we just put it on subscription?
So there,
uh,
I mean I don't,
I just take three of them,
three of each,
boom.
But I had never read like how much should I be taking this a little bit more
like strong like this.
I'll tell you what I take.
I take three of each in the morning and I take three at night.
I know that's good and that's fine.
But what is the recommended you're talking to the guy that orders the 40 ounce
steak to be good.
More is better after a 48 hour recommended,
I would say.
I would say depending on your way,
but I'd say like two and two.
Take two of each in the morning,
two of each at night.
And also you can,
you can also do this.
You can also,
you know,
see where you're at.
Right.
Like you know what it feels like when you haven't been taking your like yeah.
So then up the dose.
That's what I did and I've been real,
real confident with where I'm at.
Yeah.
I mean two,
three and three for me.
Not twice one one time,
three and three.
Boom.
Morning.
I got to get a lot of subscription though.
That's good.
I like that option cause I run out and uh,
and then and then it takes days to,
yeah,
it,
that's what sucks is it takes like three days,
right?
Three days you're like,
oh my,
oh I haven't been taking it and then you got to get back on it and it takes
another couple of days.
It's wack subscription if you're into it.
We're like,
can you get that anyways all like that.
Well this is more stuff.
What?
Yeah.
If you want to go get it right now,
origin main.com that's where you get it.
also@originmean.com also Jocko supplement,
it's called discipline.
It's a pre admission cognitive enhancers,
micro dose of caffeine.
If you're into it,
just like Jocko white tea,
you're all,
I just wanted the bottle just sampled.
So tasty.
Yeah.
See Tasty,
which is,
I mean maybe,
yeah.
I mean again,
I know I said it before,
but it,
it doesn't seem like you're all like focused on taste because you're not focused
on looks.
No,
not at all.
Yeah.
But you liked the taste
and make sure it's the stuff tastes good apparently.
But uh,
it is good stuff.
I take that one every day too.
When do you take it?
Morning now?
Pre,
pre day life free day Manulife.
You know why?
The way I see it is like there's no caffeine or there's not like huge amounts of
caffeine.
So it's like,
okay,
if I'm going to microdose I ripped that off from Tim Ferriss.
Microdosing microdosing LSD and microdosing cycle drugs and whatever sounds
cool.
That's not really my thing,
but I'll take a little micro dose of caffeine,
15 milligrams.
Sure.
But give you a little glimpse into the spirit world.
I don't think you'd do it well.
The LSD might.
Yes,
for sure.
Oh
yes.
Let me get some of that sometime.
I just figured that like the cognitive enhancing,
enhancing nutrients.
I figured that's like a thing that's not like a drug.
Right?
It's nutrients.
So that's he's taking every day.
So your brain is just generally more capable.
It's just what I figured.
Maybe that's why he's answering all of these good questions.
So they got the discipline and maybe the neurons are firing.
I've been on it.
That's why I got those stripes.
19% increase in performance.
Thanks for and,
and the rest her to do that by the way also anyway.
Um,
get them@originmain.com also@originmain.com is where you get your key straight
up.
You have origin g I do have an orange.
Again,
they're,
they're awesome.
I had comments on all the time.
They're uh,
there,
Greg [inaudible].
They're,
they're super lightweight but they're super strong and,
and uh,
yeah,
definitely my favorite game.
I'm looking to get another one mind too and made it in America by the way.
Brian emailed me yesterday.
You might think that's the best thing about origin geese that it made in
America,
but then it's not because he'd get the gate and you realize that.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
because if it was made in America and then you're like [inaudible] the other
night I was rolling in the deaf.
Yeah.
The interesting thing,
we obviously we don't,
I'm not a fashion guy.
Right?
Well,
I mean clearly I'm not a fashion life can tell you want to see your stories.
You can tell like to tell stories about my fashion escapades from 1987 tapered
jeans.
Danner,
combat boots.
Right.
That's how I roll.
But when you put it on the deaf guy that everyone says something,
why is that?
It's just cause it looks because it's not flashy.
It just says discipline equals freedom and then it says get after every time I
walked by people when I'd walk by,
then I'd hear him going to get after it.
And you know what Pete is like that though.
What has like an element of fashion in his stuff?
No,
I know.
I got to put them in check on that.
I had to go back and forth a little bit of like,
Hey,
you got to put that in check.
You want to,
cause he made some,
he made some spats.
Oh yes.
Which is an approved term now.
Wave compression pants.
Compression pits.
Tights is what?
Super Superman and call them Spanish.
But anyways,
he made some of that work.
Is that like jeggings?
No Jake,
way too far.
Their genes,
but they're late.
It's,
I know this because my daughter has some chick to teenage girls.
You don't know what jeggings arc about?
They're like legging slash jeans.
Well yeah.
Pete has more fashion sense cause he's got that whole design thing going on.
Yeah.
Like he's a designer.
He's a creative.
I know you listed in your all designing stuff up there.
Me,
I'm like make it black.
What can we add to it more black and what kind of shape do you want in the
waistline or it just like,
I,
I don't know about that kind of stuff with pizza.
Don't worry.
I got it.
And that's why until he designed the,
the multicolored spats.
Whoa.
That's just like just taking it again or I can't even,
I can't even,
I'm not even,
I have to put myself in check here because I realized that that is beyond my
domain of competency right there.
That is way beyond my domain of competency.
So if you want to get those spots,
go for it.
But to Pete's credit,
guess what they have now black black spots.
If you need them you can get them.
Boom.
But even here,
even the other gies though,
people before I got the deaf one,
people would be like,
oh that's a nice geek.
What's really interesting is when you see that we've,
yeah,
we've is what makes it gorilla.
Yeah.
But there's like this little pattern in the raven actually the first one of the
first ones I actually held was years life cause you've,
you've got an origin GE for a long time.
Yeah because you asked me a long time ago before I was even with origin,
you're like,
hey what kind of gift shops don't get a damn origin game.
Awesome coming.
You would tell me about it and you went and got one.
I went and bought one.
It was good and I was like,
God damn,
this thing is nice.
But yeah,
there's a pattern.
All right,
cool.
We get it.
Sorry,
I'm just saying crazy.
He don't care about the fashion of people.
Sneak it in there just for like fashion.
I got to watch out for Pete.
Subtle fashion.
It's good.
Keep it up.
I think also some rash guards,
they're all made in America and some other stuff.
Check it out.
If you'd like something,
get something.
Origin main.com is the ups site also on [inaudible] dot com slash Taco kit on
it.
This is where I get my kettlebells.
Kettlebells,
kettlebells.
Yeah.
So I've got the whole set,
primal bills,
all that stuff.
Also maces and other workout stuff.
If you want to,
you want to switch it up.
You don't want to do a boring workout anymore or you're bored with your
workouts.
Switch it up on it.com/chocolate checkout the workout gear.
It's good.
Get something.
Also,
when you buy extreme ownership way,
the word kid or any of the books Jocko may or may not review on this podcast.
Um,
don't worry.
I organize all those books.
I made a shirt too,
by the way.
It's a whole nother story.
We'll go into that later.
But I organize all the books by episode by the way.
Um,
get them through their good way to support it will take you to Amazon,
get your book and whatever else you're getting.
And uh,
you know,
carry out lawn mower.
No sat lately.
A lot of lawnmowers.
People buying lawnmowers.
He's ready for spring.
Yeah.
For the Amazon.
Click through.
Yeah.
I think I'd stay there to support.
Can you buy a driving lot more?
Cause when I think lawnmower,
I think drew Amazon,
you probably can probably here like this.
I bought a leaf blower and I'm not joking.
There you go.
My daughter plays with it.
Recharge.
Get it once.
Can you get an 84 millimeter recoilless rifle,
Carl Gustaf I don't think so.
No.
You've got to go somewhere else to show that is a damn shit.
One of my buddies was asking me that the day he was going to go shooting and,
and he's uh,
he's a British guy and his name is English.
Peta and sure and English pizza don't hold that guys shoot and they call them
English as his nickname,
English Peta,
p.
E t,
a.
H,
English,
Peta.
I think this pizza was going to go shooting with someone and he says,
Hey,
you know,
want to go?
He says,
Hey,
I'm going to go shoot tinker.
Would you like to come?
And maybe we could work on some covered move.
And I was like,
I was like,
I can't make it.
And then I saw him later and I said,
oh,
how was the shooting?
He says,
oh,
we didn't get to go mate,
or does it go,
couldn't go,
couldn't go.
And I said,
oh,
that's a bummer.
I said,
you're going to like it.
He goes,
I really want to shoot is like the RPG.
And I was like,
that's going to be a little tricky.
Check Amazon.
Yeah,
Amazon.
I don't think they provide that kind of stuff,
but if they do,
hey,
whatever.
You know when you buy your book by one of those,
cool.
Also subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already,
stitcher,
iTunes,
Google play,
Spotify,
Spotify.
I do what?
There's a bunch of other podcast apps and I don't even know what their names
are.
I need to start tweeting the,
the locations of those have got to figure them all out.
Yeah.
Well,
and there's a bunch.
Yeah,
and they're coming out with new ones.
It's like this,
you'd think we,
well,
we kind of said before you'd think,
oh,
iTunes.
Right.
That's what podcasts are.
But the podcast is a podcast and hey,
what's interesting,
and I haven't seen this factually or I don't know where that number came from.
So like two years ago,
18% of America was listening to podcasts.
1818 like when we started,
that's the number I got.
I was like researching all how many people are listened to her right now?
So it's been two years.
48% of Americans listen to podcasts.
And that right there is explosive growth.
It's pretty amazing because it's a great medium.
Yeah.
It's like kind of like having a commerce,
well,
I guess it depends on the podcast,
but yeah,
I agree fully.
Please subscribe if you want.
Good way to support also youtube,
subscribe to Youtube.
If you want,
if you're interested in the video version of this podcast,
we ever guessed Leif Babin the guests episodes.
That's when people watch them.
Typically.
Mostly.
Mostly,
yeah.
Well,
I don't want,
yeah,
not even really.
Mostly I'm just saying we see more people watching the episodes with,
with guests.
I want to see what they look like.
A parody.
Yeah.
Unless if you're interested in that and excerpts.
If you don't want to necessarily watch the whole podcast,
you've watched just like little clips of it or whatever,
you want to share them with your friends,
whatever.
We provide that as well.
Also enhanced excerpts.
That's what we're calling them now.
Some of that too.
Anyway,
various video types on there.
I've seen you've been a little bit more your spear throwing more punches now
let's go a little bit more.
Yeah,
more.
we're going to keep that going,
so yeah,
there'll be more clips to choose from.
You know,
you don't listen or watch or whatever.
Yeah,
so he has subscribed.
Good way to support.
Also,
Jack was a store.
It was called Jocko store.
Of course.
[inaudible] dot com that's where you can get discipline equals freedom shirts,
victory MMA shirts.
Someone Jocko wears every day while we do the podcast and otherwise,
and you don't get out anyway.
This shirts on this podcast,
shirts,
Jocko gear shirts also rash guards,
also hoodies,
also hats.
Did you mention a new shirt?
Is there a new shirt?
I mentioned new shirt cause it out cause I haven't approved or seen anything.
No,
it's good.
It's good.
Authorize.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's in limbo right now,
but I,
I'm very,
we're confident.
It's like the patches.
He secretly wants you to do it.
Yeah.
Now this one he's going to openly,
I think you'll approve cause there there's no colored shirts yet approved and
then you know,
actually it's called back to the book.
Oh no surprise.
We talked about it before but I,
it's coming along with a few layers on there and I'm,
you know,
I'm going to go ahead and offer it,
offer it up.com.
Can't release it until there's enough layers.
Yes,
no.
Yeah.
Layer lists,
shirts or unapproved.
Who has the most,
the shirt that I designed is the most layered shirt.
Is that correct?
Yes.
I think that's good.
You said you submitted quite easily there.
It's true.
The truth.
You have the woody call it the gift of truth or what it was it,
I don't know when they're like,
hey,
what if the,
our competition is gossiping about us?
You have the big weapon,
the weapon or the truth.
The high ground.
Yeah.
So you've got numbers on your site nonetheless.
Chocolate store.com.
That's where you can get all the cool stuff.
Check it out.
If you want something,
get something.
Also,
psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks,
Jocko tracks.
When you run into those moments of weakness in your campaign against weakness,
speaking of which,
uh,
so I'm getting my car,
you know,
I've got thousands of songs on my iTunes.
Yeah,
I get,
I get in my car,
you know how to it.
I have my Bluetooth on and he realize it,
but it just automatically syncs up to my trucks.
I jump on my truck and,
and the,
I didn't realize the radio was kind of a high volume.
Apparently.
I think my kids would be screaming in the backseat.
So I'll play like some kid kiddos,
but I get in there,
I get in there and uh,
and all of a sudden it's like Jockos voice.
I mean,
I get it,
I'm not paying attention,
backing up and it's like,
it's Kinda weird.
Does Discipline Cope?
And of all the random,
you know,
thousands of songs that I have on my iTunes,
like that comes up.
I was like,
what are the odds?
And it was actually something I needed to hear at that moment,
uh,
and,
and to,
to remind me to give back all the bath.
So that is something that's extremely helpful.
Perfect.
Um,
and uh,
the,
the universe universal line,
diverse Charles for that,
and it may cause Echo Charles originally said to me like,
Hey,
what do you do here?
And I answered him some question.
It was a,
it was like,
he's like,
well,
how do you not skip
workouts?
And I was like,
I bumped up,
up,
up.
He's like,
Bro,
we need to record that and put it out so people can listen to it.
And he's like,
and you should answer the rest of them.
You should be like,
what?
How'd you get out of bed?
And drives us.
All right.
Ask me the questions.
And that's where it came from.
Echo Charles.
Yeah.
A little additional thing.
You know how the cane,
I don't know if you've run into this where you're,
you're like,
shit,
I have Outta,
I'm confused,
or I don't have the answer for this thing.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to ask Jocko what is just,
what is he think?
Right?
As you're asking them,
you're like,
oh,
I know what he's gonna say or it.
Right?
So this one,
he was like,
oh.
I was like,
oh,
I know what this guy's going to say right now.
He's just going to stop being weak or something,
something like that.
So it was more like,
I get it.
Stop being weak.
Okay.
But there was a little bit more to that,
like,
what do you say?
Like what do you think?
Or whatever,
you know,
something like,
all right,
yeah,
we're going to record that.
And these chocolate trucks,
they have it for anything,
not just skipping workouts for procrastination,
getting up early,
all this stuff.
So it's kind of like,
even if your volumes not turned up,
it's kind of like Jocko is actually telling you like
hottest,
not skip the workout.
It's good.
It's encouragement.
Yeah.
I would say what's funny is happening,
people are always like,
oh you should make a thing of you yelling at me to get out of bed.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I thing that would work,
but it would only work like a few times after a while it's kind of like,
oh yeah,
cool.
Shut him according of Jocko yelling.
But if you,
you know how like you're talking like you know,
so like it's kind of like you're explaining,
you know,
like this is this,
what's going on,
this which good kind of thing.
It's,
it's enough of a reminder of that.
Kay,
get back on the path.
There you go.
But yeah.
Good one.
Get down one on iTunes.
It basically anywhere where they sell in.
Yeah.
It's available.
Psychological warfare.
We support the also when you're on Amazon you can get Jocko white tea.
Now the good thing about there's some good things and bad things about Jocko
white tea,
the bad things or is you got to mix it up with hot water.
That can take a little extra time.
The good things is once you drink about a half a cup of white tea,
and this is what we're finding now,
when you drank about a half a cup of white tea,
you are then able to deadlift 8,000 pounds.
A lot of people are wondering how much you had to drink and the answer is you
can drink a half a cup and you're there so you can get Jocko white team and it's
also legal in which a lot of people are trying to get it out loud right now by
the athletic commission and the Olympics.
They don't want people on the records and everything,
so yeah,
they're trying to just ban it but get it while you can get it while you can,
before it gets bad,
before it gets banned and then you're just done.
Also some books,
the books that I read on the podcast for sure.
There's also a book called a lot of the books I read in the podcast or are for
adults,
clearly a lot of more very,
you need a mature audience,
but kids also need to know how to get on the path.
And my right,
you've got kids,
you got kids.
Kids need to know how to get on the path.
How are they gonna get on a path?
Well,
number one,
they can get the book way of the Warrior Kid and they can get on the path with
that.
And now there's another book coming out.
It's way the warrior kid to sequel,
the sequel.
Cool.
Could it be,
but jaws to fail.
There's always that chance.
If I would've listened to my publisher.
Yeah,
cause the,
what do they want to do?
They want you to churn out,
hey,
you've got a little bit going here.
Let me get another one that's ride the wave.
Right.
And by the way,
let us help you shape,
you know,
where we think we,
this could go.
Oh,
so you just want to take it down that path to no,
we're not going down that path.
Life's hard.
Mark's gonna face some more struggles and he does.
Luckily he's got an uncle Jake comes and help him out.
Weigh the word kid marks mission.
You can preorder it right now.
It comes out April 24th is the date that it comes out.
You can get that.
Also,
if you're an adult and you want to get on the path to stay on the path,
be on the path,
move down
the path.
You can get a book called Discipline Equals Freedom Field Manual,
which echoes apparently knows all about field manuals.
My favorite kind of man,
you have a favorite kind of manuals.
This is going to help you stay on the path.
That's what it's gonna do.
Not only what you should think about in a section called thoughts,
but also the actions you should take if you want to proceed to get stronger,
faster,
smarter and all around better.
And if you want the audio version,
don't look for it on audible cause it's not there.
This is an album also with tracks and it's available in MP three format from
Amazon music from Google,
play from other MP three platforms
and actually life.
Talk a little bit about,
I dunno,
a couple books.
We wrote a little company,
we got maybe a little event that we're doing.
First and foremost,
if you want to dive deeper and the leadership principles that we've been talking
about and referencing get extreme ownership.
That's we have people ask us like,
Hey,
what did you make mistakes in your career?
We wrote a whole book about him and that's when he screamed.
Oh,
she was about the mistakes we learned on the battlefield,
the things that happened to us,
what we learned from them.
Um,
and then how that principle applies a business in life.
So go get that book on Amazon or anywhere that you can buy books.
And if you're like me and you're super busy and you don't have a lot of time to
read,
um,
then,
uh,
you can get the audible book now,
the audio book,
it's on audible,
it's on anywhere,
uh,
and uh,
and get,
uh,
get that version.
And we read it by the way we read it,
the James Earl Jones wasn't available.
So parents is Batman was we,
we,
uh,
we had to read it.
I didn't realize it was the Texas Batman until people are listening to this
book.
Yeah.
That's where that was born on social media.
I hear good things about the audio version though.
There's,
there's little surprises in the audio version that it wants.
Again,
we didn't listen to our publisher.
Our publisher was like,
well that's kind of weird to put that.
Well we,
well,
what do you,
would you rather hear for gunfire?
Uh,
you know,
me going or would you rather hear gunfire?
What would you rather hear for an explosion?
Lafe going,
Kaboom.
Or would you rather have an explosion?
What would you rather have for the call to prayer life?
Talking about the call to prayer coming?
Cause it's,
it can be pretty eerie in those situations.
Or would you rather actually hear it?
So there's,
what would you call that?
Uh,
audio theater.
Sure.
You make it into call it that.
Okay.
And they did a great job with that,
with the audio book.
So get that,
that's certainly an option as well.
Uh,
and if you have a company or you want to work,
work with us,
uh,
echelon front,
that's our,
that's our company that's not in front of you.
And if you're looking to,
uh,
to implement these leadership programs into your team,
learn from us,
learn,
learn those same principles that we talk about.
Um,
then that's what we do and Islam front is we,
we come out and work with your team,
we,
uh,
and we come out and work with your
team and,
and get these principles apply to your particular challenges that you can lead
and win on your battlefield.
And that's just that,
that what echelon front is,
is our company is Jocko,
it's me,
it's de Berg,
it's j p and l guys that you know from,
from this podcast and a,
and a whole team of folks is Jocko talks about the tank where we talk about
these leadership problems,
we solve those problems and,
and we help you lead and win.
And that's awesome.
We love that.
So if you're interested in and working with us,
go to a echelon front.com and of course the muster,
which you talked about,
this is the ultimate leadership conference.
Uh,
and an F.
We've got four of these so far.
Every single one of them have sold out every single one of sold out.
So don't wait if you were interested in common,
uh,
we're only doing two this year.
We're only doing two.
We had a lot going on for us and we said we're going to do two amazing monsters.
A,
that's what we're going to focus on.
We did three last year,
but we're only doing two this year and that's in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th and that's in San Francisco October 17th and 18th.
And that's it.
If you want to,
uh,
if you want to come and be a part of the monster,
go to extreme ownership.com and get registered and we'll see you there.
And until the muster,
if you want to kind of continue this conversation that we're having right now,
you can find us continually conversing.
As far the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram,
me
and on that face he ball
Lafe is that Leif Babin
go is at Echo Charles and I am at Jockowillink Echo Charles.
Anything else?
No self correcting machine.
That's what happens when you start doing the extreme ownership thing.
Does the added layer I gathered from today?
Legit.
I like it.
Thanks for [inaudible] clarify.
Oh it was good to see you.
Nice forever.
Maybe not always,
but if any closing thoughts.
Good to be on.
Again,
we're looking forward to the next time.
I suppose we'll do one more of when we're up the muster we'll talk more.
They will talk more about,
probably talk a little bit about extreme ownership.
Maybe we'll talk a little bit more about the new book,
which will be done for the most part by then.
Awesome.
Obviously thanks for coming on.
Thanks to everyone out there,
especially those of you who are out there in uniform who have basically said,
I am willing to give everything I have for freedom or we're here today because
of you.
So thank you.
Thank you to the police and the law enforcement and the firefighters and the
paramedics and the rest of the first responders that do their job every day,
every day to make sure that we are safe here at home and everyone else out there
that's listening and sharing and supporting this podcast.
Thank you.
But don't just,
and don't just support and don't just share,
but instead
wake up every day with a mission.
Wake up everyday with a goal to be a little bit better than you were yesterday
and become the self correcting machine
that's not going to bring you to perfection,
but it's going to bring you to a place that's a little bit closer to get out
there and get after it.
And until next time,
this is Lafe and echo and Jocko
out.